SUBCOMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER
GOOD MORNING- IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE. HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES HAVE ACCESS TO
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARING.
IN THE CAPITOL AND SOME MEMBERS
ARE ABLE TO- PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY TODAY ALL THE ACTUAL
MEMBERS OF THE SBCOMMITTEE I
WILL BE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE THERE ALSO. OR
WILL BE- PROTESTING REMOTELY FOR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MEET
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID LIMITING AN
ACOUSTIC- FACTORY I S. IT EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZE
THAT YOU. USED TO RAISE YOUR
HAND FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM EACH
TIME WE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A
POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO UN MUTE
PLEASE SELECT A NEW BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING ARE I. T. PERSON
I WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE. BUT
WHEN YOU'RE DONE MUCH RECOGNIZED
TO SPEAK UP PLEASE MAKE SURE
THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND THEN
YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS TO COME-
THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIRES
ALLOW. AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE. INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR- ALL-
INDIVIDUALS WHICH TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMON TO PURCHASE TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
POSTED ON THE SCREEN N. AS WELL
AS ON DISPLAY AND OUR WEBSITE IN
TODAY'S PARTICIPATION NUMBER IS. 877-226-8188 ONE SIX THREE
THAT'S. 877-262-2681 SIX THREE
ANY ACCESS ACCESS CODE IS.
TWENTY SIX FORTY FIVE ONE TWO
FIVE FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HEALTH TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
AT WORK- COMMITTEE WEBSITE WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY THE MOTOR
TO DIAL ONE EIGHT ZERO PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR THE OPERATOR TO
SIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS CAN
BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE RECEIVED
RELY NUMBER WE WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATE TO CALL
YOU YOUR LIFE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME. HE WILL BE A MUTED ANNUAL
ARE NOW BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
SUBCOMMITTEE PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK
YOU TOO MUST MEET THE DEVICE
THAT YOU'RE WATCHING THE HEARING
IT ON PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY
OF THE PHONE IT'S IMPORTANT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE I WILL REMAIN
TO COURT I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AN INDIVIDUAL WHOSE
DISTRICT WILL BE REMOVED FROM
THE ROAD MEETING SERVICE. OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE HEARD FOR
ALL OF DISCUSSION. ITEMS THAT
HAVE BEEN PRESENTED. LASTLY FOR
WHO ARE. PRESENT PLEASE KEEP
YOUR MASS ON COVERING YOU NOSE
AND MOUTH AT ALL TIMES. WE HAD A
QUORUM AND NOW WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM SO. LET'S HOLD OFF AN
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM AND LET'S
GO TO OUR DISCUSSION ITEMS ON
OUR AGENDA. WHICH WOULD WHICH
WILL START OFF WITH. ITEM NUMBER
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF CAL
RECYCLE. AND RECOVERY- AND
OVERSIGHT ON CAL RECYCLE.
MORNING DIRECTOR- HOW MUCH SHE
WAGNER. GOOD MORNING SENATOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME
TODAY IT IS WONDERFUL TO SEE
EVERYONE. OR BE SEEN BY EVERYONE. SUCH AS IT IS HERE IN THE MATT
WORLD OF MASS. LEGISLATORS
EXACTLY EXACTLY AND I AM NOT
SURE HOW YOU WOULD LIKE TO
PROCEED BUT I DID PREPARE AND A
PRESENTATION TO OPEN UP ON THOSE
THREE KEY ISSUES THAT THE SUB
COMMITTEE HAS ASKED ME TO
PRESENT ON AND I'M HAPPY TO DO
THAT IS THAT IS. THE PLEASURE OF
THE CHAIR. THAT WOULD THAT BE
FINE WITH TO THE PRESENTATION
HAVE FOR THE AUDIENCE OUT THERE.
THE COMMITTEE SAID REQUIRED IN
SIGN IT BUT HE ASSOCIATES
HIMSELF WITH THE LETTER WAS SENT
TO- THE DIRECTOR LAST WEEK THE
DIRECTOR RESPONDED YESTERDAY
WITH OF A FIVE PAGE LETTER SO WE
HAVE EXCHANGE OF LETTERS AND
DIFFERENT QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE- HAS. HAS ASKED BUT
BEFORE YOU DO YOUR PRESENTATION
LET'S ESTABLISH A CORPORATE MISS
ROY YOU CAN CALL THE ROLL. WHAT
KASKY. HERE SALLY. REQUIRED YEAH
STERN HERE OKAY QUORUM IS BEEN
ESTABLISHED DIRECTOR MARGIE
WAGNER PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
SO MUCH SENATE. WELL I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COME BACK BEFORE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE I KNOW YOU ALL ARE
VERY VERY BUSY AND SO I WILL
KEEP MY PRESENTATION RELATIVELY
SHORT BUT THE SUBCOMMITTEE CAME
BACK AND ASKED ME TO TALK ABOUT
THREE HEATH THINGS ABOUT THAT
HARTMAN IS WORKING ON- AS WE
MOVE FORWARD TO BUILDING OUR
CIRCULAR ECONOMY AND MEETING THE
BOTH LEGISLATIVE GOALS AND
MANDATE. AND THAT YOU ALL HAVE
GIVEN US THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THE FIRST AND FOREMOST THING
THAT I IF YOU WILL INDULGE ME
FOR A MOMENT THAT I WANTED TO
SHARE WITH YOU I HAVE A
PRESENTATION AND I WILL SHARE MY
SCREEN HERE. AND EVERYBODY SEE
THAT L. A SLIDE SHOW ARE YOU
JUST DOING IS GREAT. JUST THE
SCREEN COURSE I HAD IT BEFORE
AND NOW IT'S NOT WORKING. HE.
I DO IT. IMAGE APOLOGIES SENATOR. OKAY EDIBLE FOOD RECOVERY
GRANT PROGRAM THE CENTER RIGHT
GOOD OKAY HERE WE GO. AND SO IF
YOU'LL DAHLE THREE JUST FOR A
SECOND I WANTED TO SHARE POWER
CYCLE HAS ADOPTED A NEW MISSION
STATEMENT FOR OUR DEPARTMENT AND
THAT WE HAVE NOW PUBLISHED ON
OUR WEBSITE AS OF LAST MONTH AND
THAT REALLY TRULY REFLECTS WHERE
THE LEGISLATURE HAS DIRECTED US
TO GO IN THE IMPORTANT MISSION
THAT WE HAVE IN FOR FILLING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL- GOALS AND
MANDATES AND NEEDS OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. OUR MISSION
STATEMENT IS TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENT AND
CLIMATE FOR THE HEALTH AND
PROSPERITY OF FUTURE GENERATIONS
TO THE REDUCTION REUSE RECYCLING
OF CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION DISASTER
RECOVERY AND THE TRANSITION FROM
A DISPOSAL TO A FULLY CIRCULAR
pMOUTHFUL BUT WE TAKE OUR MISSION
VERY SERIOUSLY AND IN COMING TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY AND SHARING
THE THREE THINGS THAT YOU ASKED
US TO TALK ABOUT WHERE WE ARE ON
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR
CIRCULAR ECONOMY GRANT. WHERE WE
ARE IN IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR
NEW- TODAY DISASTER DEBRIS
RECOVERY OPERATION AND WHERE ARE
WE ON AND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
OUR BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
PROGRAM ALL REALLY TRULY GOES TO
MEETING THIS NEW MISSION THAT
THE DEPARTMENT HAS DEVELOPED IN
ADOPTED IN REALLY TRULY- AND
MEETING AS THE LEGISLATURE'S
DESIRE THAT WE AT AND THE
GOVERNOR'S DESIRE THAT WE
TRANSITION TO A CIRCULAR
ECONOMY. SO FIRST AND FOREMOST.
I'M VERY PROUD TO SHARE. AT WE
HAVE AT THE ARE THE I BELIEVE-
NINE AND ALLOCATIONS THAT WE
RECEIVED AND THEN- BUDGET LAST
YEAR THAT YOU ASKED ME TO TALK
ABOUT THE PROGRESS ON WHERE WE
ARE IN AND ALLOCATION AND
EXPENDITURE OF THE FUNDS THAT
WERE APPROPRIATE IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET- YOU WILL SEE VERY NINE
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE HERE AND
HOW IT'S BEEN DEBATE BETWEEN THE
TWO YEARS- AS YOU KNOW THAT THAT
THE DOLLARS THE TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION WAS APPROPRIATED
OVER A TWO YEAR PERIOD AND SAY
THIS IS HOW IT'S BEEN DIVVIED UP
BETWEEN THE TWO YEARS. AT THIS
NEXT FIGHT IS WHAT I THINK AND
FOR ME AS A VISUAL LEARNER IS
REALLY- ILLUSTRATES THE
DEPARTMENT- COMMITMENT WE
DEVELOP TO THIS TIMELINE AND THE
DAY AFTER THE LEGISLATURE- AND
PASSED AND THEN THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED AT THE BUDGET SO THAT WE
CAN FACILITATE GETTING AS MUCH
MONEY OUT AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
SO AS YOU WILL SEE OUR FIRST
RAMP PROGRAM AT THE TOP OUR
ORGANICS WHAT WE CALL THE B.
LIST WHICH WAS I GRANT THAT HAD-
AND- I ELIGIBLE FOR OUR LAST
YEAR'S GRANT BUT- WHERE WE
DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO
FIND. WE AND- REACHED OUT TO THE
- GREAT APPLE K. AND HAD THEM UP
. THEIR WORK- AND THEN WE MADE
AWARDS IN OUR FAT AND OUR PUBLIC
MEETING IN FEBRUARY. I'M I WILL
GO THROUGH ALL OF THESE BUT JUST
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THAT THERE
ARE A COUPLE HERE THAT WE ARE
ALREADY MAKING AWARDS FOR SO THE
ORGANICS THE LAST- WE ARE MOVING
THROUGH OUR CO DIGESTION. WHICH
IS A NEW GRANT PROGRAM ARE CO
DIGESTION GRANT PROGRAM WHICH WE
WILL BE OUT MAKING AWARDS LATER
THIS SUMMER AND AS WE DEVELOP
THAT CRITERIA WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS OVER THE COURSE OF
THE FALL. AND THE SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE LOCAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM WHICH AS YOU KNOW IS THE
SIXTY MILLION THAT GOES TO OUR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WHO ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF IMPLEMENTING. OUR
ORGANICS WASTE PROGRAMS AT WE
WENT ABOUT VERY QUICKLY SCOPING
OUT THAT GRAHAM PROGRAM
DEVELOPING CRITERIA AND WE DID
IT IN A WAY THAT WAS FORMULAIC.
TO MAKE IT AS EASY AS POSSIBLE
FOR OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
APPLY FOR THIS FUNDING BUT ALSO
SO THAT WE CAN. PROVIDE BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT WILL BE
NECESSARY TO SHOW THAT OUR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS USE THIS TO TRULY
AND TO TRULY IMPLEMENT AND-
AUGMENT THE EFFORTS THAT THEY'RE
MAKING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
IMPLEMENTOR EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
THREE THE WE RECEIVED FOR OVER
FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
APPLICATIONS. THE DEADLINE WAS.
AND IN JANUARY AND WE WILL BE
MAKING THOSE A WAR. THE FIRST
ROUND OF AWARDS WILL GO OUT AT
THE BEGINNING OF APRIL FOR THOSE
JURISDICTIONS BUT DO NOT HAVE AN
ORDINANCE OR RESOLUTION IN PLACE
AS PROVIDED BY- THE REGULATIONS
AND- ON JANUARY FIRST BUT FOR
THOSE JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE
RUNNING A LITTLE BIT BEHIND. WE
WILL HAVE A SECOND PERIOD OF
AWARDS THAT WILL HAPPEN THIS
SUMMER SO RECOGNIZING SOME OF
THAT SOME OF OUR JURISDICTIONS.
AND HAVE STRUGGLED TO MEET THE
JANUARY FIRST DEADLINE WE ARE
WORKING WITH THOSE JURISDICTIONS
THROUGH A NUMBER OF OUR PROGRAMS
ARE LOCAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS.
AS WELL AS THIS GRANT PROGRAM TO
TRY TO ACCOMMODATE THE NEEDS
THAT THE JURISDICTIONS HAVE- I
KNOW AS A DIRECTOR. MUCH LIKE A
PARENT I SHOULD NEVER HAVE A
FAVORITE PROGRAM BUT ONE OF MY
FAVORITE PROGRAMS IS THE EDIBLE
FOOD RECOVERY PROGRAM AS YOU ALL
KNOW AND- AND HAVE I PROVIDED
APPROPRIATIONS OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS SINCE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TO THIS PROGRAM. FROM
GIGI R. F. WE HAVE AWARDED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF BRANSON'S TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND HAVE BEEN GIVEN AN
ADDITIONAL. FIVE MILLION OVER
THE NEXT TWO YEARS THE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION THAT WENT OUT FROM
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY
TO. FACILITATE ED- ET PROJECTS-
ACROSS EIGHTY DIFFERENT AS AND
I'LL GRANT GRANTEES- FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO NONPROFIT. AND IT
IS LOCATED. ALMOST A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION MEALS SERVED TO-
OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT ARE
FOOD INSECURE. AND IT ALSO IS AT
THE END THAT IT WAS ALL FOOD
THAT WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE GONE
TO WASTE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. IT
IS ROUGHLY THE EQUIVALENT OF
TAKING BETWEEN TWENTY AND THIRTY
THOUSAND CARS OFF OF THE ROAD-
WITH THAT TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF GRANTS SO WE
ARE VERY PROUD OF THIS PROGRAM.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE THAT WE HAVE
DEVELOPED NEW CRITERIA OUT WE
WANTED TO AND- UPDATE OUR
CRITERIA FOR THIS PROGRAM TO TRY
TO REACH SOME COMMUNITIES THAT
WORK. I REACHED IN THE PREVIOUS
FOUR YEARS OF GRANTS- INCLUDING
PRIORITIZING- I'M OUR TRIBAL
NATION PARTNERS AND WE HAD
RECEIVED THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF GRANT
APPLICATIONS. ARE FOR THE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE WILL
HAVE TO WAR SO WE WILL BE MAKING
THE FIRST AWARDS I'M HERE IN
MARCH AND JUST A COUPLE OF WEEKS
YOU WILL SEE THAT FIRST LAST.
AND I HAVE A PROJECT THAT WILL
BE AWARDED WITH THE FIRST THREE
MILLION DOLLARS AND THEN WE WILL
BE DOING A SECOND AWARD IN JULY
WITHOUT MONEY. I'M AND THEN AT
THE BOTTOM OF THIS LIST YOU WILL
SEE THOSE THAT WE ARE SOME NEWER
PROGRAMS AND COMMUNITY
COMPOSTING IS NOT A NEW PROGRAM
BUT WE ARE UPDATING THOSE
CRITERIA TO AGAIN. TRY TO
FACILITATE MEETING THE NEEDS OF
OUR COMMUNITIES AS THEY ARE
IMPLEMENTING. THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE AND DOING MORE OUTREACH TO
COMMUNITIES THAT WE HADN'T
PREVIOUS READ SO ARE STILL. THIS
TIME- AS WE ARE WARNING THESE
OTHER GRANTS REALLY LOOKING AT
THE CAPACITY PLANS THAT WILL BE
COMING IN THE SPRING FROM OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND FIGURING
OUT HOW TO WE OVERLAY. THE
RESOURCES THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS GIVEN US AND TO HELP OUR
COMMUNITIES WITH THE GREATEST
NEED IN THE STATE- FROM OUR
LARGE PROJECTS WHICH CAN BE LIKE
HEY DIGESTION AND ANAEROBIC
DIGESTION. YOU ARE SMALLER
PROJECTS LIKE COMMUNITY COMPOST
AND LAST BUT CERTAINLY NOT LEAST
WE ARE I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
ROLLING OUT- AND WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS NOW AND THINKING
ABOUT HOW TO WE AND- PROVIDE
GRANTS FOR RECYCLING TECHNOLOGY
THIS IS A BRAND NEW CONCEPT HERE
WHERE WE ARE TRYING TO DEVELOP.
THE FEASIBILITY PLANNING
CAPACITY HERE AT THE STATE LEVEL
TO HELP. ATTRACT PRIVATE
BUSINESSES THAT CAN REALLY FILL
GAPS WITHIN OUR CIRCULAR ECONOMY
THIS IS REALLY EXCITING AS WE-
ARE BUILDING OUT OUR OFFICE OF
INNOVATION RIGHT NOW AND- AND-
GETTING READY TO HIRE THE LEAD
OF THAT OFFICE. THIS WILL BE A
REALLY IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO DO OUTREACH TO SOME OF
THOSE INNOVATORS AND
ENTREPRENEURS WHO ARE THINKING
ABOUT REALLY CREATIVE IDEAS.
AROUND NOT ONLY RECYCLING BUT
REMANUFACTURING AND HOW CAN WE
REALLY CHANGE THE MARKET ALLEN
AND PUT CALIFORNIA AT THE LEAD
NOT ONLY FOR THE NATION BUT THE
GLOW- IN BUILDING A CIRCULAR
ECONOMY SO ALL OF THIS TOGETHER
GOES TO WHAT. YOU THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED US LAST
YEAR IF YOU DEVELOP A CIRCULAR
ECONOMY PLAN AND I THINK WE ARE
WELL ON OUR WAY. AND TO MAKING.
A GREAT DEAL OF ACCOMPLISHMENTS-
I HAVE A- OF- JUST I CAN ROLL
QUICKLY THESE A COUPLE OF-
GRANTEE ILLUSTRATIONS HERE JUST
TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF THE
ORGANICS BRAND SO YOU CAN SEE.
WE'VE DONE QUITE A BIT AROUND
COMPOSTING- THIS YEAR AND THE
PAST COUPLE OF YEARS I'M A
COUPLE OF THE INNOVATIVE IDEAS
AROUND- ANAEROBIC DIGESTION AND
THEN THE CITY OF STAND AS STUDY
VEIL IS THAT IS. BEING UP IN THE
AND USING THOSE TECHNOLOGIES I'M
WHICH I THINK WILL BE A REALLY
EXCELLENT COMPLEMENT TO WHAT WE-
ARE SEEING BILLS ACROSS THE
STATE AROUND CO DIGESTION. SO
ALL OF THIS TOGETHER WILL GO
WITH THE COMMUNITY COMPOST ACT
SB CAPACITY PLANS THAT WE SHOULD
BE SEEING IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
MONTHS. TO HELP US REALLY DRY
OUT A MAP AND A LANDSCAPE OF
WHERE OUR RESOURCES ARE MOST
NEEDED- AND THEN HOPEFULLY NEXT
YEAR WE CAN HAVE A NUMBER NOTHER
CONVERSATION OF REALLY WHAT THAT
LANDSCAPE LOOKS LIKE. FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I HAD TO
GIVE THE IS LEGISLATURE AN IDEA
OF HOW WE'RE DOING AND. AND
WHERE WE'RE DOING OUR BEST WORK.
I'M THESE ARE JUST SOME EXAMPLES
OF OUR EDIBLE FOOD RECOVERY
GRANT PROGRAM I STAFF YOUR
ACCOUNT WAS LIKE ALWAYS KNOW
THAT I LOVE TALKING ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM BECAUSE YOU'RE A
RELATIVELY SMALL INVESTMENT
MAKES A HUGE IMPACT- OUT OF VERY
VERY GRASSROOTS LEVEL SO THIS IS
THE ST FRANCIS CENTER IN LOS
ANGELES WE GAVE THEM SEVEN
HUNDRED SIXTY THREE. THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO PURCHASE TWO
REFRIGERATED BOX TRUCK SO THIS
IS REALLY JUST INFRASTRUCTURE-
AND IT FACILITATED. FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND POUNDS OF
EDIBLE FOOD RECOVERED IT IS JUST
REALLY- REALLY PHENOMENAL- AGAIN
I HAD THE CONTRA COSTA AND
SOLANO COUNTY FOOD BANK AND AS
WAS AWARDED THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR SOME TRACKS
AND OTHER EQUIPMENT AND THEY'VE
RESCUED- OF OVER ONE POINT THREE
MILLION POUNDS OF FOOD TO DATE-
AND ARE ARE PRETTY PROVIDING
SOME REALLY INCREDIBLE LOCAL JOB
OPPORTUNITIES- SO I WILL SKIP
AHEAD. THIS IS OUR CO DIGESTION
PLANTS- IN AND- LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND ALSO IT'S AND
DIVERTING- AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT
OF- AS FAST FOOD WASTE FROM THE
LANDFILLS ALREADY I'M TO GO TO
ILLUSTRATE THAT WE ARE-
SPREADING OUR OUR RESOURCES
ACROSS THE MANY DIFFERENT TYPES
OF PROJECTS THAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE MORE OF YOUR IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND THAT WE'RE
GOING TO NEED MUCH MUCH MORE OF
THAT IN THE COMING YEARS I'M SO
WITH THAT AND BEFORE I MOVE ON
TO DEBRIS ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS ON- ORGANIC WASTE AND
OUR. CIRCULAR ECONOMY BRANDS. GO
AHEAD AND KEEP GOING OUR MY
NUMBERS KEEP. HOW DO YOU GET IT
JUST MAKE SURE I KNOW I'M I KNEW
SHOES NUMBERS QUICK JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE I'M NOT WE ANY. SO I
HAD THE COMMITTEE ASKED THAT I
COME AND TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
AND THE PROGRESS WITH OUR
DISASTER DEBRIS RECOVERY
OPERATION OUR FUTURE- DIVISION
WE ARE REALLY REALLY EXCITED TO
SHARE THE PROGRESS THAT WE'VE
MADE OVER THE PAST YEAR AND WHEN
I CME ON BOARD I SAT DOWN WITH
THE DIVISION HAD- TINA WALKER TO
TALK ABOUT HER DIVISION AND WE-
QUICKLY IDENTIFIED- SOME CHANGES
THAT COULD BE MADE TO MAKE HER
DIVISION WORK MORE EFFECTIVELY
SHE- JOINED US FROM- HELLO YES.
AND SO IT BECAME VERY OBVIOUS
AND NATURAL FOR US TO REFORM HER
DIVISION TO LOOK MORE LIKE AN
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT TEAM TELL.
YOU THE FIRST SECOND I'M GONNA
READ SOME NUMBERS BECAUSE I'M
NOT OTHERWISE GOING TO REMEMBER
IT AND EVERYTHING THAT SHE
SHARED WITH ME THAT AND WE HAVE
AT CREATED THREE TEAMS. AND THAT
CAN BE SIMULTANEOUSLY DEPLOYED
ACROSS THE STATE OR CONTRACT.
MANAGEMENT HEALTH AND SAFETY- I
ALAN'S I- HAVE. I THINK SENATOR
MCGUIRE ONE OF THESE
SPECIFICALLY STAFFING WE HAVE
FAILED ALMOST ALL OF THOSE
POSITIONS WE ARE GOING TO WE
FAILED OUR THREE WASTE
MANAGEMENT ENGINEERS. AS AND
JUST THIS PAST MONTH I FEBRUARY
WE ARE WORKING ON INTERVIEWS
RIGHT NOW FOR OUR NEW WASTE
MANAGEMENT ENGINEERS- THAT WERE
RE CLASSIFIED TO A GPAS FOR OUR
CONTRACT MANAGERS. AND THEN WE
FILLED OUR NEW SENIOR WASTE
MANAGEMENT ENGINEERED
SUPERVISORY ROLE IN SEPTEMBER
I'M AND THEN WE HAVE ONE
ENGINEERING GEOLOGIST THAT IS
GOING TO BE RECLASSIFIED TO A
STAFF SERVICES THIS IS ALL GUYS
DOUBLES. I WILL DIE WILL SKIP
AHEAD I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT I'M
I'M STARTING TO UNDERSTAND ALL
OF THIS STARTED. AND THAT WILL
BE ADVERTISED IN MARCH SO WE
HAVE SOME STAFFING THAT WE ARE
STILL WORKING ON DOING BUT WE
ARE OUT BY THIS SPRING- AND IT
IS A PAINTING BEING FULLY
STAFFED UP WITH THE THREE TEAMS
THAT WE HAVE REDEVELOPED AND RE
CLASSIFIED. FOR THE TYPE OF WORK
THAT THEY'RE DOING IN THE FIELD-
ADDITIONALLY WHEN I CAME ON
BOARD IT WASN'T NECESSARILY THE
CLASSIFICATIONS WERE NOT EXACTLY
THE RIGHT FIT FOR THE KIND OF
WORK THAT WAS NEEDED. AND LIKE I
SAID- HE DID A GREAT JOB AND
HELPING US. VERY QUICKLY TO
BUILD- AT THE BACK DISASTER
DEBRIS TEAMS THAT ARE EASILY AND
QUICKLY DEPLOY- AND TO
ILLUSTRATE THAT. OUT WE WERE
DEPLOYING AND ISSUING CONTRACTS
COURTESY OF OUR LEGAL TEAM AND
OUR ARJUN DISASTER TEAM- BEFORE
THE DIXIE FIRE WAS- DONE
BURNING- UNFORTUNATELY AS WE ALL
KNOW IT BURN FOR A VERY LONG
TIME BUT WE WERE ABLE TO START
OUR DEBRIS REMOVAL OPERATION
EVEN BEFORE THE FIRE HAD
COMPLETED- AND- EVEN FURTHER
ILLUSTRATION. CAL RECYCLE AND
HELLO YES WE ARE INDEED HAND
PARTNERS- IN AND MEETING THE
RECOVERY MISSION. ON AND OUR
PARTNERS AT DGSE- THE STATE OF
COLORADO AS THEY- EXPERIENCE
THEIR DAMAGE DEVASTATION EARLIER
THIS YEAR OR LATE LAST YEAR. AND
REACHED OUT TO US TO ASK HOW DO
YOU DO A DEBRIS RECOVERY
OPERATION POST WILDFIRE BECAUSE
THEY LOOKED AT THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING HERE THIS YEAR AND
SAW THAT WE HAD HAD
SUCCESSFULLY- BUILD A SYSTEM.
AND THAT IS THAT IS WORKING SO.
TO THAT POINT- OR AT AS-
OVERALL- SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
OUR PROGRAM IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN- WE'VE CLEANED UP TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND HOMES RESPONDED
TO OVER FIFTY DISASTERS- AND
HAVE BEEN IN THIRTY THREE
COUNTIES- BUT WHAT REALLY GOES
TO ILLUSTRATE WHERE WE ARE TODAY
IS. ALL RIGHT ON WHAT IS TODAY
MARCH THIRD WE ARE 77% DONE WITH
THE STRUCTURAL DEBRIS REMOVAL
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE-
DISASTERS- I THINK JUST HOVERING
AROUND 20% DONE WITH THE TREE
REMOVAL- FROM FROM THESE
DISASTERS WHICH AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW WHO ARE ARE TRACKING
EMERGENCY RESPONSE TO RECOVERY
IS REALLY VERY VERY CHALLENGING
AND A LOT OF THESE AREAS OF THE
STATE THAT ARE VERY REMOTE- AND
DESPITE. THE WEATHER CHALLENGES
THAT WE EXPERIENCED AT THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
BEGINNING A TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE
ARE MAKING INCREDIBLE HEADWAY
AND REALLY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
CLOSE OUT THIS OPERATION. BEEN
FINISH THE DEBRIS REMOVAL- BY
THE SPRING WHICH IS JUST
INCREDIBLE- AND SO I REALLY JUST
WANT TO APPLY TO THE TEAM HERE
AT OUR CYCLE AND HELLO YES AND
THE- AND WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
BUILD. I'M LOOKING TOWARDS THE
FUTURE WE ARE AND WE ARE. VERY
EXCITED THAT WE ARE ROLLING OUT
SOME NEW TOOLS THAT WE HAVE A
MASTER SERVICES AGREEMENT FOR
OUR MONITORING AND ASSESSMENT
CONTRACTS THAT WENT OUT TO BED
AND AT MARCH SECOND IT WILL BE
BACK ON MARCH ELEVENTH- AND SO
FOR OUR FUTURE OPERATIONS WE
WILL HAVE A READY MADE TOOL. AND
ALREADY- HAVE CONTRACTORS- READY
AND WAITING- DO YOU TO GO TO%
WORK AT FOR OUR FUTURE.
OPERATIONS THROUGH THAT MSA AND-
THROUGH GDS IS HELPING DEVELOP
NOT. FOR OUR CONTRACTORS ARE
REMOVING AND DOING THE ACTUAL
DEBRIS REMOVAL YOU ARE CURRENTLY
DEVELOPING A PRE QUALIFIED
BIDDERS LESS SO AN MSA WAS NOT
THE APPROPRIATE TOOL. FOR THOSE
CONTRACTS BUT WE ARE DEVELOPING
A PRE QUALIFIED BIDDER LESS TO
GET AND DISTILLATE TATE A VERY
QUICK DEPLOYMENT WHEN I'M AT AT
EIGHT AND DISASTER OCCURS. AT SO
WE HAVE HAD A LOT OF REALLY GOOD
CONVERSATIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
WE ARE VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE
PROGRESS THAT WE'RE MAKING- THAT
IS NOT TO SAY THAT THIS THAT WE
DON'T NEED TO CONTINUE MAKING
PROGRESS WE AS I'VE ACTUALLY
SAID. HAVE BEEN- BUILDING THIS
PLANE AS WERE FLYING AND LANDING
AT ALL AT ONE TIME ON A VERY
STRICT TIMELINE POST DISASTER SO
WE CONTINUE TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS
WE ARE MAKING PROGRESS- IS ONE
OF THE THINGS I LOVE TALKING
ABOUT BECAUSE IT'S- VISIBLE
PROGRESS THAT WE ARE MAKING.
EVERY DAY IN THIS PROGRAM- WITH
OUR OTHER STATE PARTNERS SO I AM
VERY EXCITED TO SHARE THAT. WITH
ALL OF YOU AND SENATOR THAT
FINAL HE'S IS THERE A- BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAM SO I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT ME TO
STOP THERE AND- AND THEN JUMP IN
OR IF YOU WANT TO KEEP UP.
FOLLOWS ONE OF WE HAVE CENTER
DOLLY HAS A QUESTION ON THE-
WILDFIRE DEBRIS CLEAN. RIGHT SO.
SOMEBODY WHO IS EXPERIENCED THE
CAMPFIRE. THE CAR FIRE IN THE
DIXIE FIRE ALL DEVASTATING-
COMMUNITIES IN MY DISTRICT. WELL
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
EXPERIENCED IS THAT WHEN YOU
SAID YOU HAD PRE QUALIFIED- OF.
DEBRIS REMOVAL PEOPLE. WHAT IS A
COMMUNITY JUST BURN DOWN AND YOU
DON'T USE THE CAR. IN THE
COMMUNITY TO ACTUALLY. REBUILD
OUR COMMUNITY OR OR CLEAN UP
THEIR COMMUNITIES SO IT'S A
DOUBLE HIT BECAUSE THE
CONTRACTORS COME. FROM OUT OF
THE AREA THAT ARE PRE QUALIFIED
AND SO I WORKED WITH UP. MARK
GHILARDUCCI AND CAL AND- CALLOW
YES ON TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE LOCALS. HAVE THE WORK
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY IF
YOU BRING THE CONTRACTORS FOR
SOMEONE'S WE SAW THIS ON THE
ORAL DAM AND WE SAW THIS ON ALL
THE PROJECTS THAT- WERE DISASTER
PROJECT AND SO I AM VERY.
CONCERNED THAT YOU'D- MAKE SURE
THAT THE LOCALS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO KEEP THE DOLLARS
THAT. ARE GOING TO BE PUT INTO
THE COMMUNITY TO REVITALIZE IT
STAY IN THE COMMUNITY BECAUSE
IT'S A DOUBLE HIT WHEN WE DON'T
HAVE THAT. THAT IS SESSION THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT POINT
SENATORS AT SUCH AN IMPORTANT
POINT. IN PREVIOUS CONTRACTS AND
AGAIN EVERY YEAR IS A NEW
LEARNING OPPORTUNITY AS WE AS WE
REALLY BELT. AND OF THE FIRST OF
ITS KIND AT A STATE RUN RECOVERY
OPERATION. BUT I AM VERY
FAMILIAR WITH. SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES IN PREVIOUS
OPERATIONS AND THIS CONTRACT FOR
THIS YEAR WE NOT ONLY GAVE
PREFERENCE THATREALLY LOOKED
FOR- VISIBLE METRICS- FROM OUR
CONTRACTORS ON HIRING LOCAL WORK
FORCE AND WE ARE IN
CONVERSATIONS AS WE DEVELOP OUR
PRE. PRE QUALIFIED BIDDER LAST
WE ARE IN CONVERSATIONS WITH-
LABOR ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL AS-
LOCAL LABEL OR DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATIONS ON HOW DO WE BEST
INTEGRATE. OUT LOCAL AND HIRING
PRACTICES INTO OUR PRE QUALIFIED
BIDDER- PRACTICE OF THIS IS ERY
MUCH A PART OF WHAT WE'RE HOPING
TO HAVE A VERY STRONG POLICY AND
ROLL OUT AS PROJECT PART OF OUR
PRE QUALIFIED FEDERALIST. BUT I
COULDN'T AGREE MORE- HAVE GONE
TO GREEN I WHEN HE SENATOR. AND
ENDING UP AT THE DIXIE FIRE AND
SEE ANTI COME. ABSOLUTE DEBT.
AND REALLY WANT A TO BE AND PART
OF THEIR RICK. REALLY TO. THAT
THAT- INVESTMENTS- IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES AND FACILITATE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR- THESE THAT HAVE
LOST THEIR HOMES BUT ALSO THEIR
JOBS TO REALLY- PART OF THE
RECOVERY AND WORK THROUGH THIS
WITH US AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THAT COMMENT. I JUST WANT TO
GO ON THE RECORD BECAUSE THAT
ALWAYS IT'S NOT ALWAYS WORK THE
WAY. THAT WE WANTED TO WORK AND
THAT MEANS THAT THE LOCAL THE
LOOK THAT THE PRE APPROVED
CONTRACTORS. TYPICALLY ARE NOT
FROM THE AREA THERE STATEWIDE
CONTRACTORS THAT ARE BIG
CONTRACTORS BUT THE SUBJECT OR
NEED THEM- SHOULD BE COMING FROM
THE LOCAL AREA AND I NOTICE IT
YOU'RE YOU'RE TRYING TO GET
THERE BUT- ON THE GROUND. YOU
CAN GO TALK TO THE LOCAL
CONTRACTORS AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
NOT WORKING AND THEY DON'T MEET
THE CRITERIA SO I JUST WANT TO
GO ON RECORD NOT THE COMMITTEE
HERE NO. BECAUSE I'VE
EXPERIENCED IT MANY TIMES AND
IT'S REALLY NOT FAIR- BUT I KNOW
THAT YOU'RE WORKING TOWARDS A
BETTER. HOPEFULLY GOD WILLING WE
WON'T HAVE A LOT MORE THESE
DEVASTATING YOU KNOW COMMUNITIES
BEING DESTROYED- BUT IT SEEMS TO
BE HAPPEN MORE AND MORE SO I
JUST WANT TO GO ON RECORD YOU
KNOW THAT IS IT ISN'T AS EASY AS
IT SOUNDS. IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT
TO GET THOSE LOCAL CONTRACTORS
WORKING IN THEIR THERE AND
THEY'RE AVAILABLE AND THAT MONEY
STAYS IN THE COMMUNITY THANK YOU
IT IS EXACTLY RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THAT SENATOR. SENATE
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
RESEARCHER AT FIRST AND FOREMOST
ON ON THE ISSUE OF DEBRIS AND
DEBRIS HAULING I WANT TO. TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
DIRECTOR. AND THE DIRECTOR HAS
BEEN. ENGAGED AND INVOLVED AND
ALL ISSUES. SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF HER TENURE HERE. LAST YEAR IT
CARRIED CYCLE AND THIS ONE IS
HOW GRATEFUL I AM. INDEED JUST.
BACKGROUND CARRY CYCLE. IS A
WHOLE DIFFERENT AGENCY THAN WHAT
THEY WERE BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. ESPECIALLY WITH THE
SIZE AND SCOPE OF THESE
WILDFIRES OVERSEE- FIVE WE'VE
COME A LONG WAY SINCE THE VALLEY
FIRE VALLEY FIRE WAS THE FIRST.
MASSIVE FIRE THAT CAN RECYCLE TO
CONSOLE LEAD TO BE ABLE TO-
CLEAN UP COMMUNITIES IN LAKE
COUNTY. AND THAT AND THEN UNDER
DIRECTOR MISALIGNED- IN GRATEFUL
TO TRIGGER WAGNER FOR HER. FOCUS
ON THIS. PROJECT AND TALK ABOUT
SOME SPECIFICS IN REGARDS TO THE
POSITIONS THAT AMOUNT OF
DIRECTOR YOU JUST MENTIONED. YOU
IT SAID THE VAST MAJORITY NOT
HAVE BEEN HIRED LAST YEAR IN
THIS BUDGET SUB THERE ARE STILL
CHALLENGES ABOUT BRINGING FOLKS.
ON BOARD IF YOU CAN JUST GIVE US
SOME SPECIFICS ON THAT AND THEN
I WILL GO TO MY. SECOND QUESTION
THE MASTER SERVICES AGREEMENT.
OF COURSE SENATOR SO. AND EXIT
AND GET HAULAGE FOR GETTING INTO
SOME SERVICE SPEAK BUT AS I
NOTED- WE HAVE. REORGANIZED TO
THIS DIVISION AND TO LOOK MORE
LIKE AN EMERGENCY RESPONSE
DIVISION COMMANDER AFTER
COMMANDER TO REAL QUICK CAN WE
TAKE. THE SLIDE DOWN TO SO WE
CAN SEE THE DIRECTOR SCREEN IS A
FULL. SORRY SECOND. YOU CAN ARE
SHARING YOUR- THAT WERE YEAH
WELL GO RIGHT TO INSECT THANK
YOU SO MUCH DIRECTOR VERY HIGH
IT'S. FONG I WOULD JUST OUT IS.
AND NOT MANY FOR DO- ONLINE
PRESENCE. I SO FOLLOWS NOW
LIVING THE DREAM SOON THESE. I
TOTALLY GET IT. HEY AS WE SAY.
WE TOOK WHAT WAS. I MEAN REALLY
DELYLAH. AS A CLEAN UP- JIM AND
WE LOOK AT IT DID. BECAUSE OF
THE NEED OF THESE AT BEING
DESIGNED RECOVERY AND I'M
RESPONSE. WE KEPT AT EXPERTISE
IN RESPONSE AND WE TOOK A AND
I'VE HEARD OF IT TO LOOK MORE
LIKE A NUMBER WITH TO BE. SO ARE
BILL OR HAVE NOW REACHED THAT
CAN BE DEPLOYED SIMULTANEOUSLY
THAT HAVE AID FINANCE LEAD-
WHICH IS THE CONTRACT MANAGER.
AND TO SAFETY OFFICERS AT TWO
DHUBRI GROUP SUPERVISORS SO
ANYBODY WHO'S BEEN OUT TO AN
OPERATION KNOWS THERE ARE A LOT
OF MOVING PARTS AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE ON VARIOUS SITES. AND
SPENDING ALL OF THE PARCELS ON
ANY GIVEN DAY AND ONE I'M
OPERATIONAL PLANNING LEAVE AND.
IT COINCIDES VERY VERY WELL.
WITH THE TEAMS. ECHO ADD
CALLAWAY. AND IT ALIGNS VERY
WELL SO ONCE WE DID THAT I WHAT
I LIKE TO ASK ACTUALLY TO AS A
MINI. AND RE CLASSIFY AND SOME
THE POSITIONS WE HAVE FROM LAST
YEAR I'M HONESTLY AS I HAD TO
TELL YOU AND A LOT OF THE PEOPLE
WHO WORKED ON THE PREVIOUS
OPERATIONS- I DECIDED THAT THEY
NO LONGER WANTED TO BE IN THESE
POSITIONS BECAUSE THEY WERE
DEPLOYED FOR SIX SEVEN EIGHT
MONTHS OF LAST YEAR AND- THE
TOLD IT TOOK ON THEM PERSONALLY.
WAS A LOT AND THEY WANTED
SOMETHING A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
SO WHAT WE DID IS WE TOOK THOSE
OPEN POSITIONS WE RE CLASSIFIED
THEM TO BE MORE APPROPRIATE FOR
THE SPECIFIC JOBS THAT WE NEED
UNDER THIS REORGANIZED
STRUCTURE- AND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE. HERE WASTE MANAGEMENT
ENGINE ENGINEER POSITIONS THAT
WERE RE CLASSIFIED Q. ASSOCIATE
GOVERNMENTAL PROGRAM ANALYST
WHICH IS A BROADER-
CLASSIFICATION- FOR THE TO
CONTRACT MANAGEMENT POSITIONS
THOSE INTERVIEWS ARE CURRENTLY
UNDER WAY TO FILL THOSE TWO
POSITIONS. WE HAD- THREE WASTE
MANAGEMENT ENGINEERS THAT WERE
RE CLASSIFIED- FOUR THREE DEBRIS
GROUP SUPERVISORS POSITIONS
THOSE ARE FILLED IN FEBRUARY- WE
HAVE AT ONE SENIOR WASTE
MANAGEMENT ENGINEER THAT WAS
JUST TURNED INTO A SYMBOL OF
SENIOR CIVIL ENGINEER. THAT WAS
FILLED IN SEPTEMBER. AT AND THEN
WE TOOK OUR GEOLOGIST AND TURNED
IT INTO A STAFF SERVICES MANAGER
POSITION SO MORE OF A MANAGEMENT
POSITION- TO BECOME AS A TRIBAL
COORDINATOR SPECIFICALLY FOR
THIS PROGRAM AND THAT WILL BE
ADVERTISED HERE IN MARCH. AND SO
AND YEAH ADICIONAL LEE WE ARE
HIRING FOR A LIMITED TERM EIGHT
GPAS FOR INVOICE. I
INVESTIGATION AND REVIEW AND
THEN- I. FOR FOUR FIELD OFF IN
DEGREE GO. THE BRICKWORK SUPER.
MY GOODNESS I'M SO CURRENTLY WE
HAVE- OUR TO FILL. MODIFY AND-
TEAMS FOR THREE CONCURRENT
OPERATIONS BASED ON THE CURRENT
STAFFING THAT WE HAVE AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE WE HADN'T SOLD ANY
OF THOSE POSITIONS BUT MOST OF
THOSE POSITIONS WERE FILLED- AND
THEN WE HAD- AS- AS STAFF LEAVE.
AS A AS A NOTED AND AFTER THE
LAST OPERATION- AND NOW WE ARE
STAFFING UP AGAIN AND TO HAVE
THREE PEOPLE TEAM. WE SHOULD
TURNED LOOK INTO THE I THINK OF
THE ITEMS IT WOULD LIKE TO BE A
LOOK TOWARDS THE FUTURE NOT AT
THIS TIME. IS THAT OKAY CANDIDLY
BURNOUT IS GONNA BE INCREDIBLY
HIGH WITHIN THESE POSITIONS
BEING DEPLOYED AND IN SUCH
DRAMATIC- CIRCUMSTANCES SO I
THINK THIS IS GONNA BE SOMETHING
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO LOOK AT-
WITH CAL RECYCLE IN THE FUTURE.
I HAVEN'T CHECKED IN WITH THE
DIRECTOR ON THIS BUT I IT'S
VITAL WHICH GETS ME TO THE NEXT
POINT. AND THAT'S ON THE MASTER
SERVICES AGREEMENT. LOOK BOTTOM
LINE IS YEAR AFTER YEAR IT'S
GETTING WORSE YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
THE NUMBER OF TIMES THAT
REMOVING- YOU COMPARE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN. TO WHAT WE DID
LAST YEAR IT'S NIGHT AND DAY
IT'S SIGNIFICANT. I'M IN WHAT I
APPRECIATE THE DIRECTOR LOOKING
AT. IS A MODERN DAY. REVAMP OF
DEBRIS REMOVAL IN THE STATE. IN
MANAGER AFTER I WANT TO BE CLEAR
ON WHAT YOU'RE FOCUSING IN ON.
RIGHT NOW IN THIS MASTER
SERVICES AGREEMENT YOU WOULD
HAVE. A CERTAIN NUMBER OF PRE
QUALIFIED CONTRACTORS THOSE
CONTRACTORS WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO AGREE TO WHAT A SET OF
STANDARDS WOULD BE THAT THE
STATE WOULD EXPECT. AND YOU
WOULD HAVE THEM PRE QUALIFIED SO
THEY ARE PREPARED TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE. HOPEFULLY HEFTY LIST SO
THAT WERE MOVING. SEVERAL DEBRIS
OPERATIONS AT A TIME. AND THEY
CAN MOVE QUICKER THAN HAVING TO
BE ABLE TO GO THROUGH FOR
EXAMPLE A THIRTY TO FORTY FIVE
DAY R. P. TO BE A TO BRING THEM
IN BETTER DIRCTOR I WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT I AM TRACKING IN WHAT
YOUR GOAL IS TO BE A TO GET
THESE FIRMS ON BOARD. THAT IS
THAT IS EXACTLY RIGHT SENATOR SO
FOR A LOT OF THE CONTRACT THESE
ARE VERY VERY RIGHT HERE AT THE
CENTER OF WHAT HOUSING AS A AS A
HOMEWORK PROJECT THIRTY ONE NO.
AT ITS CURRENT CONTRACT FOR YOU. JUST THANK YOUNG LITTLE HIRED
AS- I'M THESE CONTRACTORS ARE.
VERY VERY DETAIL AND- A LOT OF
THE CON. WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS
FOR A TWO YEAR PERIOD OF TIME
THIS IS GOING TO BE OUR CONTRACT
AND SO IF YOU COME IN A BID TO
US TODAY WHICH IS WHAT THEY'RE
CURRENTLY WORKING ON- YOU ARE
PRE QUALIFIED. WHEN IT COMES TO
THE SPECIFIC OPERATIONS SO IF
IT'S A SMALL OPERATION AND- IN
LAKE COUNTY OR A LARGE
OPERATION. IN AB YOU COUNTY. YOU
ARE ALREADY QUALIFIED AND WHEN
IT COMES TO THE SPECIFICS THEN
THE AND DETAILS OF THAT
OPERATION. WE WILL HAVE SOME
ABILITY TO PICK THOSE THAT ARE.
BASED ON THE NEEDS OF THAT
OPERATION AND THEIR OVERALL
ABILITY TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THAT OPERATION BUT THEY WILL
ALREADY BE QUALIFIED TO
PARTICIPATE. IS HUGE IN THE LAST
PIECE ON THIS AND I'LL DO THIS
QUICKLY IS. WHAT YOU HAD SAID
EARLIER AND PARAPHRASING- AND
DIRECTORS ON THE ISSUE OF
LOOKING AT FOR EXAMPLE DIFFERENT
TRADES- WHETHER IT'S- COULD BE
OPERATING JIM NEARS OR LABORERS-
EXEDRA. WORKING WITH THEM SINCE
THEY ALREADY HAVE THE TRAINING
PROGRAMS IN PLACE TO BE ABLE TO
GET THIS- THE QUALIFIED
PERSONNEL UP AND RUNNING AND
THEN I THINK IT ACTUALLY GETS
TO. SENATOR DONNELLY'S POINT.
WITH THESE. THAT SPECIALIZE IN
THE CITY'S CRASS- WHAT THAT
QUALIFY WORK FOR RIGHT LIKE FOR.
WITH PREMJI NEARS THEY CAN GET
THEIR FOLKS UNDER HAS WHOPPER
TRAINING. AND READY TO MOVE AND
I THINK THAT'S WHY. THAT'S ONE
OF THE REASONS WHY YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THAT TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE THAT WORK FORCE READY TO
MOVE ON A MOMENT'S NOTICE
CORRECT. THAT IS EXACTLY RIGHT
AND I THINK THIS IS ONE OF THE
PLACES WHERE- WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO. A LOT OF
OUTRAGE AND A LOT MORE WORK TO
REALLY AND HEALTH. I AND IT TOO
MOSTLY THROUGH COMMUNICATIONS
WITH WHETHER IT'S OPERATIONAL
MANAGERS ARE THE LABORS FOR OUR
LABOR DEVELOPMENT WORKFORCE
BOARDS IN- IN THESE REGIONS. TO
SAY HERE'S THE SKILL SET THAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR HOW CAN WE
START TO BRING IN. A BUILD OUT
THIS WORK FORCE I THINK WE WERE
ALL HOPEFUL AFTER CAMPFIRE- THAT
WE WERE GOING TO SEE LESS AND
LESS OF THAT THAT AND
UNFORTUNATELY I THINK YOU KNOW
OUR REALITY- ACT. BECAUSE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE IS THAT WHERE WE
ARE FOR THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE
GOING TO BE AND THE WILD FIRE
AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE AND
DEBRIS BUSINESS. SO HOW DO WE DO
THIS IN A WAY THAT REALLY IS
MOST RESPECTFUL TO THE TO THE
VICTIMS OF THESE DISASTERS THAT
REALLY GIVES THEM AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BE A PART OF THEIR RECOVERY.
AND REALLY SERVESTHEM IN THE
BEST WAY POSSIBLE AND I THINK
THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE NEED TO DO MORE- ANYTHING
FALL. IS WHEN YOU'LL BE READY TO
ROLL. THERE'S IT IS NOT WHAT
THANK YOU. TO ME YOU KNOW I LIKE
TO HAVE EVERYTHING TOMORROW BUT
THERE LOT PEOPLE HAVE TO GET ON
BOARD THAT WE THAT THINGS THAT
WE DO IT SO I'M LEARNING THIS
PAGE BUT ONE OTHER THING I WANT
TO KNOW SENATOR SINCE WE WERE
TALKING PLACES THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD LIKE TO DO- ARE IS I KNOW
A LOT OF YOU AND HE REPRESENT
AREAS THAT ARE IMPACTED BY
WILDFIRES ALSO REPRESENT SOME OF
OUR TRIBAL NATIONS AND THIS IS
ANOTHER PLACE THAT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO US THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE ADMINISTRATION. WHERE WE
BUILD STRONGER RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THAT ARE OUR TRIBAL NATIONS
I'M HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
STRONGER COMMUNICATIONS THAT
THAT IS SOMETHINGADDITIONALLY
THAT WE ARE WORKING ON THIS YEAR
AND HOPING TO HAVE- A VERY
STRONG- COMMUNICATION NETWORK.
AS FOR THE NEXT OPERATION. OKAY. I GUESS IF YOU COULD JUST YOU
KNOW WHEN AN AREA GETS
DEVASTATED YOU HAVE THE DIXIE
FIRED NINE HUNDRED SIXTY THREE
THOUSAND ACRES WHERE IS THE
CEMENT I ASSUME ALL THE CEMENT
IS RECYCLED ALL THE WOODY DEBRIS
WHAT IS USABLE WHAT'S NOT USABLE
YOUR WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TREES
AND REMOVE SOME OF THEM ARE JUST
DANGEROUS BUT ARE NOT DESTROYED
HOW DOES IT IF EVERYTHING IF THE
LUMBER YARD HAS BEEN BURNED DOWN
WE'RE HOW DO YOU FEEL
LOGISTICALLY TAKE IT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT IS A PROPERLY
DISPOSE OF AT THE END HOW DOES
THAT LOOK LIKE. THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT QUESTION SENATOR SAID
THIS IS PART OF OUR CONTRACTS
WITH OUR DEBRIS- REMOVAL
CONTRACTORS IS THAT THEY NEED TO
RECYCLE AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE AND
WE HAVE SPECIFIC QUANTITIES IN
TERMS OF TREES- AND- AND HIGHEST
AND BEST USE OR AND THE DEBRIS
PRIMARILY THE TREES AS YOU POINT
OUT BUT IT DOES BECOME VERY
COMPLICATED BECAUSE I E.
SENTRIES AND IS- LASSEN COUNTY
WHERE YOU MAY NOT HAVE A LUMBER
YARD IT WOULD BE VERY DIFFICULT
TO MOVE TO VIEW COUNTY TO GET
THEM TAKEN CARE OF SO WE HAVE TO
WORK WITH EACH OF OUR
CONTRACTORS ON EACH OF OUR
OPERATIONS AROUND THIS. SPECIFIC
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE FIND IN
THAT PARTICULAR REGION AND IT
HAS BEEN A REAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITY FOR ME IN THIS
POSITION BECAUSE YOU KNOW I'VE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME ON
BROWNFIELDS CLEANUPS AND THIS IS
A VERY DIFFERENT SITUATION
BECAUSE YOUARE NOT- AS
METHODICAL ABOUT FIGURING OUT
EXACTLY WHERE YOU'RE GOING AND
IT'S NOT IN PLACES NECESSARILY
THAT ARE PARTICULARLY EASY TO
REACH AND YOU'RE WORKING REALLY
REALLY FAST YOU HAVE TO HAVE
SOME OF THIS CHART IT OUT IN
ADVANCE SO WHAT ARE PRE
QUALIFIED LIST. THESE. ARE
THINGS THAT WE CAN WE REQUIRE
OUR OUR A CONTRACT. TO OUR LIVE
US THE THEY- AND I ABOUT INTO
THE SEA I'M THEY'RE GOING TO
THIS OF THE- HOW THEY'RE GOING
TO DISPOSE OF IT AND HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO MEET THE BEST AND- THE
BEST FINAL USE FOR THE DISPOSAL.
ADDITIONALLY WE REQUIRE THEM TO
USE OUT LOW MISSION VEHICLES-
WHERE POSSIBLE SO WE ARE LOOKING
AT EVERY ASPECT OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL THE FRENCH THAT
ONE OF THESE OPERATIONS PASSED.
AND ASKING THE QUESTION OF OUR
CONTRACTORS BEFORE THEY EVER
STEP ON THE FIELD OF HOW DO WE
MINIMIZE THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT THAT YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
IN THIS IN THIS OPERATION WELL
THANK YOU WELL LET'S MOVE ON TO.
TODAY'S MAIN AFFAIR THE BOTTLE
BILL OTHERS HAVE SERIES OF
QUESTIONS THAT- PRETTY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS THAT WE ASKED IN THE-
I WILL. ALLOW YOU TO ANSWER.
THOSE AND CONTINUE YOUR
PRESENTATION. YOU KNOW I COULD
YOU. WE CAN'T A GREAT AND THE
QUOTE OR- I DID JUST AND HAVE A
COUPLE. OF LAKE. GETTING AT THIS
I THINK MAYBE. I'M AT NOPE I'M
NOT GETTING BETTER AT THIS I
THOUGHT I WAS. HI DO I SHARE
REYES VERY RECAP. ALL RIGHT THE
COUPLE BY ON I THE NUMBER
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAM AND
AS YOU MAY OR MAY NOT KNOW SINCE
THE INCEPTION IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIX MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
BILLION CONTAINERS HAVE BEEN
RECYCLED- THROUGH OUR PROGRAM
HERE IN CALIFORNIA I'M JUST LAST
YEAR IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. I IT
SAYS MORE THAN EIGHTEEN POINT
SIX BUT- WE ARE CURRENTLY AND
CONTINUE TO COMPILE THIS NUMBER
AS OF YESTERDAY I THINK IT WAS
HIGHER THAN EIGHTEEN POINT EIGHT
BILLION CONTAINERS RECYCLED IN
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM LAST YEAR
I'M WHICH IS THE HIGHEST
CONTAINER- NUMBER OF CONTAINERS-
THAT WE HAVE EVER RECYCLED IN
CALIFORNIA WAS IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. I'M AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE-
LAUNCHED PILOT PROGRAMS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE FOUR AND IN
CULVER CITY IRVINE. SAN
FRANCISCO. SAN MATTEO THAT ARE
UP AND RUNNING AND ONE ENDS AND
NUMBER COUNTY THAT IS REALLY
INNOVATING AROUND- DIDN'T AND
UTILIZING PARTNERSHIPS THROUGH
SIX DIFFERENT JURISDICTIONS I'M
THAT WILL BE ONLINE HERE- IN
MARCH. I'M. ONE OF THE THINGS
TAT I WANTED TO POINT OUT
BEFORE WE GET INTO- THE SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS BUT BUT I THINK WE'LL
LUMINATE SOME OF THE ANSWERS TO
THE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS- IS THAT
CALIFORNIA OVER THE COURSE OF
THE PANDEMIC SAYS SENSE
BEGINNING OF- TWENTY TWENTY HAS
SOLD MORE BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
THAN EVER IN OUR HISTORY SO AS
YOU CAN SEE FROM THE- OF BAR
CHART SAYS THE BEGINNING SENSE
TWO THOUSAND- WHAT HAS HAPPENED
IN TERMS OF BEVERAGE CONTAINER
SALES AND WHAT'S HAPPENED OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS REALLY
JUMPING. FROM JUST OVER TWENTY
FOUR- BILLION AT CONTAINER SOLD
TO IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS WE
CONTENT COMPLETE OUR-
CALCULATIONS WE'RE LOOKING AT
ROUGHLY TWENTY SEVEN BILLION
CONTAINER INCREASED. OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS. I'M WHAT
THAT HAS MEANT IN TERMS OF
RETURNS- THIS NEXT CHART GOES TO
SHOW YOU REALLY WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN TERMS OF RETURNS IF
YOU LOOK AT TWENTY TWENTY THAT
DEATHS THAT YOU SEE THERE THAT
IS OBVIOUSLY THAT FIRST YEAR OF
THE PANDEMIC THAT WE
EXPERIENCED- FOR HEALTH AND
SAFETY REASONS- AS MANY OF OUR
RECYCLING CENTERS TEMPORARILY
CLOSING DOWN FOR ANYWHERE FROM
ONE TO SIX MONTHS I'M SO AB AND
PEOPLE- STAYING IN PLACE. AND SO
WE DID ALLOW EIGHTEEN BILLION
RETURNS WHILE SEEING RECORD
SALES- AND THEN HEARING IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS I
HIGHLIGHTED THE BEGINNING OF THE
PRESENTATION WE ARE BACK UP OVER
EIGHTEEN POINT EIGHT BILLION-
CONTAINERS RECYCLED. I'M SO THAT
REALLY GOES TO ILLUSTRATE SORT
OF THIS FLUCTUATION THAT WE'RE
SEEING IN THIS PROGRAM- AND IF
YOU WANT A SENATOR I'M HAPPY TO
GO THROUGH SOME OF THE KEY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU ASK- AND THE
LETTER THAT YOU SENT- BUT- I
THINK THAT THE- IT TO BE A
LITTLE CHEEKY THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR QUESTION IS WHY
IS THE NUMBER. SO IS SUCH A HUGE
DISCREPANCY FROM WHAT WE THOUGHT
IT WAS GOING TO BE LAST JANUARY
AND THE ANSWER IS REALLY THE
PROJECTIONS THAT WE BUILD INTO
THE BUDGET OR THE SEMI ANNUAL
REPORT. OR OR ANY OF THE OTHER.
PLACES THAT WE WOULD PROJECT HOW
THE THAT THE FUND IS GOING TO GO
WERE OFF. USUALLY IN A RECESSION
WHERE WE'VE SEEN HISTORICALLY
DURING A RECESSION IS THAT
BEVERAGE CONTAINER- SALES GOES
DOWN PRETTY SIGNIFICANTLY- BUT
REDEMPTION EITHER IT STAYS
PRETTY LEVEL OR BUMPS UP A
LITTLE BIT AND SO WE DID NOT
PROJECT- THE SALES THAT WE ENDED
UP SEEING IN TWENTY TWENTY AND
CONTINUE TO SEE IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. AS PART OF- THE REPORTS
THAT WE DID THAT REALLY
HIGHLIGHT WHAT WE THINK IS GOING
TO HAPPEN WITH THE FUNDS WE WENT
THE MORE CONSERVATIVE ROUTE OF
PROJECTING. WHAT WOULD NORMALLY
HAPPEN DURING A RECESSION- AND
AS YOU ALL KNOW THE SEMIANNUAL
REPORT IS REALLY AIMED AT MAKING
SURE THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
AWARE- WIN THIS FIGHT AND- IS
STARTING TO DECREASE- IS AWARE
WHEN- WE ARE PROJECTING A
PROPORTIONAL REDUCTION IN AND
THE FORMULAS FOR PAYMENTS. I'M
RECTOR DIRECTOR LET ME I GUESS I
MEAN WE ALL MADE MISTAKES IN
MARCH AND APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY
OF THE GOVERNOR OUR BUDGETS
ANTICIPATED- REDUCTION WE'RE
GOING TO GO INTO A WRITTEN OTHER
RECESSION AND THAT'S THAT'S FAIR
ENOUGH THAT THERE BUT BY THE
TIME WE GOT TO DECEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY. I MEAN I THINK
ONE OF THE PROGRAMS WE HAVE. IS
WE PAY DISTRIBUTORS. TWENTY FOUR
MILLION A YEAR TO REAP TO K.
RECYCLE HOW MANY CANS AND
BOTTLES THEY'RE DELIVERING NOT
SUPPORT BEING RECYCLED BUT THAT
WAS THAT'S LIFE THAT HAPPENED
APRIL MAY JUNE JULY ALL THREE
TWENTY TWENTY. AND THEN YOU CAN
THEN IT GOT CONTINUED IN IT IN
FEBRUARY MARCH AND APRIL AND MAY
BEFORE WE DID THE BUDGET. BEFORE
DOES THE BUDGET SO DOESN'T MEAN
WE'RE PAYING TWENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THAT DATA. IT IN
LIFETIME LIFETIME IT'SNOT IT'S
NOT YOU KNOW IT'S ACTUAL IT'S
NOT ESTIMATE IS NOT PROJECTION
WE KNOW THAT IT IT'S AT THE
STORE READY TO BE SOLD. SO WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT- D. B. BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING FIND AND
WHAT IS REPORTED IN THE BUDGET
AND NOT THAT OF FOUR HUNDRED
AND- TWENTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR
NUMBER AS YOU OUTLINED IN- AND-
AT YOUR LETTER. THAT NUMBER IS
PART OF THE JANUARY TEN BUDGET
SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT OBVIOUSLY
AND I EITHER WAY. I THINK I DID
A REALLY. MEDIOCRE I WAS GONNA
SAY BAD BUT I THINK I DID A
REALLY MEDIOCRE JOB EXPLAINING
THIS TO- THE CHRONICLE REPORTER
BECAUSE LIVING AND BREATHING THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS FOR SO MANY
YEARS. I REALLY I THINK
ADEQUATELY EXPLAINED TO HIM THAT
THE WAY THAT OUR BUDGET WORKS IS
THAT THAT NUMBER IS THAT BUDGET
FIND. OUT THAT FUNDS- NUMBER IS
FORMULA EIGHT FORMALIZED- FOR
THE JANUARY TEN BUDGET AND THEN
IT CARRIES OVER INTO THE BUDGET
YEAR AND IS WHITE- AS WHAT. YOU
ALL ARE WORKING OFF THAT SO WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT THE PROJECTIONS IN
SALES AND THE PROJECTIONS OF
REDEMPTION- AND I THINK IT I
THINK PART OF THE PROBLEM WITH
WHAT I THAT ARE USEFUL WAS
COVERING IS THIS ABSOLUTE
ORIGINS. AND COMPARISON BETWEEN-
THAT FUND STATEMENT THAT IN THE
BUDGET AND WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
THE SEMI ANNUAL REPORT THAT
REPORT IS NOT MEANT TO SHOW THE
HEALTH OF THE FUNDS. THAT REPORT
WAS CREATED VERY SPECIFICALLY
AFTER THE LAST TIME WE WENT INTO
PROPORTIONAL REDUCTION BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO GET AWARENESS SO
TO PROVIDE ALL OF THESE
PROJECTIONS AND WHAT WE THINK IS
GOING TO HAPPEN TO THE FIVE. I
HONESTLY AND BECAUSE NONE OF MY
FRIENDS FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF I
CAN'T. THE END OF THE TABLE I
DON'T THINK THAT THIS REPORT
SERVES YOUR PURPOSES I THINK
WHAT YOU JUST SAID THE VERY REAL
TIME. INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THIS FUN AND WHAT
IS HAPPENING ON A MONTH TO MONTH
BASIS OUT IN THE WORLD AND WHAT
IS ACTUALLY BEING RECYCLED
SERVES YOUR PURPOSE IS SO MUCH
BETTER THAN WHAT WE STATUTORILY
REQUIRED IN THIS REPORT- AND
WOULD BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU.
STATE AIRPORT WILL BE SOMETHING
MORE USEFUL I'M GUESS I'M
WONDERING FOR ANYBODY AT
FINANCES. PAYING ATTENTION WHAT
ARE WE DO GOING IN THE MAIL. YOU
KNOW WE HAD MADE OF TO TWENTY WE
KNEW THAT. ALL MY GOD WE THIS IS
OF WORK OR DRINK AND THEY WERE
THEIR DRINK AND OF BEER TO THEN
WE HAD MAY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WE SEE THE NUMBERS ARE OFF THE
CHARTS YOU'RE YOU'RE SHOWING ME.
AND I MEAN I DON'T KNOW WHAT
WE'RE IT WHAT HAPPENED WITH
CURBSIDE DURING THIS WHEN PEOPLE
WERE IF I GET THE PANDEMIC BUT
IT'S SOMETIMES. THAT THOSE
NUMBERS COMMANDED THAT
CONTAMINATE CONTAMINATION RATE
SHOOT THROUGH THE CEILING AND
IT'S ALL IN THE LANDFILL AND WE
JUST DON'T KNOW ABOUT IT BUT NOW
WE'RE COMING ON TIM MAY OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND WE'VE GOT
YOU KNOW WE GOT PLENTY OF
QUESTIONS FROM THE CHRONICLE BUT
YOU'RE SAYING YOU. KNOW WHAT DO
YOU WHAT IS IT. WHAT ARE YOU
RELY ON IN AS- AND IF YOU DO
HAVE A FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY. NINE
MILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS. WHAT'S
THE DEPARTMENT PLANNING TO DO
WITH THIS. COME THE MAY REVISE I
GUESS THIS. IS YOU KNOW ARE WE
GOING TO IMPROVE THE BOTTOM BILL
PROGRAMMER WHAT'S UP. SERGIO YOU
TAKE A QUICK SEVEN YOU HAVE BEEN
. HE YEAH SENATOR I THINK WHAT
WE WILL WANT TO WE WILL COME
BACK WITH UPDATED NUMBERS FOR
MAIN REVISED OUT OF THESE
CONTINUE THESE TRENDS OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS- CONTINUE- IN
TERMS OF SALES AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE SEEING I DON'T KNOW THAT
WE WILL CONTINUE TO SEE THAT AS
THE WORLD IS NOW STARTING TO
OPEN UP- WHETHER WE WILL GO BACK
TO. A MORE HISTORICAL SALES
TRENDS AND ON. RECYCLING RATE
TREND- BUT I DO WANT TO SAY YOU
KNOW I DO HEY WE ARE WORKING ON
OUR WASTE CHARACTERIZATION RIGHT
NOW I DON'T ANTICIPATE
EVERYTHING'S GOING INTO THE
LANDFILL AS YOU CAN SEE ARE THE
NUMBER OF CONTAINERS. ADDED THAT
ARE BEING RECYCLED CONTINUES TO
GO. SO I THINK THAT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO HIGHLIGHT- THAT DAY
IF THE WHILE IT IS AND- THAT
RATE TENDS TO BE. I HAVE A RING
AROUND THAT 70% RATE RECYCLING
RATE I WE ARE SEEING MORE
CONTAINERS BECAUSE THE SALES
NUMBERS HAVE GONE UP SO
SIGNIFICANTLY BUT WE ARE
ANTICIPATING COMING BACK TO YOU
SENATOR WITH- HIGHER NUMBERS FOR
THE FIND IN MAY REVISED WE'RE
HERE I'LL TURN IT TO YOU WELL I
GUESS. I GUESS. MR A- THANK YOU
ARE WHAT. YOU KNOW WE GOT ALL OF
LARGE RESERVE WHAT IS FINANCES
OPINION ON WHAT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED A HEALTHY AMOUNT. YOU
KNOW WHAT ARE WE WHAT WHAT. AND
WE'RE ONLY ONE OF TWO PUBLIC
BOTTLE BILL PROGRAM SO WHAT DO
YOU THINK IS A HEALTHY AMOUNT
FOR THE RESERVE. L. WHAT'S A
GIVE ME GIVE ME THE MINIMUM AND
THE HEALTHY. YEAH THIRTY EITHER
PART OF FINANCE I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE A SPECIFIC NUMBER AND IN
TERMS OF WHAT. KIND OF HELP YOU
FOUND. SB BRIDGES AT THE LIBRARY
ON ODD RECORDS WAGNER'S COMMENTS
BUT WE DO AGAIN YOU KNOW UPDATE
OUR OUR REVENUE PROJECTIONS FOR
MOST FUND BACK UNDER THE BUDGET
ACT AND THAT MAY BE FIVE. AND WE
HAD. ADDITIONAL INFORMATION. TO
PROVIDE I THINK IN IN THIS CASE
WE'RE DEFINITELY LOOKING AT THE
TREND THAT I THINK-
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THE CONSUMER
BEHAVIOR THAT HEARD WHAT WILL
DEFINITELY. NOW WE HAVE TO
DEBATE IT- STILL KIND OF THE
UNCERTAINTY OF WHETHER THAT
CONSUMER BEHAVIOR WILL CONTINUE.
I THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE WE'RE BALLOT THEY- THAT
KIND OF BE YOU KNOW IF WE DO IT
THROUGH MY HIGHER. LEVEL OF
BRITAIN YOU KIND OF WHAT THAT
SHOULD LOOK LIKE. AND THEN
DEPENDING ON WHAT THE BALLOT ONE
BALLOT LOOKS LIKE YOU KNOW WHAT
ARE SOME POTENTIAL KIND OF OTHER
STRATEGY THAT THOUGH- THAT DON'T
YOU KNOW WE'RE DEFINITELY
MONITORING BUT WILL DEFINITELY.
I HAVE- WILL LOOK AT ANOTHER
REVENUE- AT THE MEASURE FOR
RUTHLESS. FOR THE REVISION. SO
ARE THERE ARE VOWED TO READ
MONCHI THERE OF WAYS TO MAKE THE
RIVER. OF THAT NOW. IN ABOUT
BILL. MORE ACCURATE AND MORE
TIMELY YOU HAVE OTHER-
OPPORTUNITY THAT YOU. SHARE WITH
THE CAN TODAY. AT YOU MAY KNOW
WE DO OUR PART I'M MORE- REAL
TIME INFORMATION ON OUR WEBSITE
ABOUT WHAT'S BEING RECYCLED AND
THOSE MONTHLY NUMBERS COME OUT-
THANK YOU NOTE THAT IT. THE SEMI
ANNUAL REPORT IS VERY
SPECIFICALLY BUILT OFF OF THOSE
BUDGET NUMBERS AND- AND HAS
STATUTORILY REQUIRED CERTAIN
ESTIMATES AND PROJECTIONS THAT
GO INTO IT SO. I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO SIT DOWN WITH YOU SENATOR AND
TALK ABOUT WAYS THAT WE CAN MAKE
THAT REPORT MORE USEFUL. DO YOU
IN THE BUDGETING PROCESS TO
REALLY HIGHLIGHT THE THINGS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE THINGS- IS
IMPORTANT. IF WHAT TRULY THE
BALL IS TO FIND OUT WHETHER OR
NOT THIS FUND IS GOING TO
PROVOKE INTO FOR PARTIAL
REDUCTION. I'M HAPPY TO NOTIFY
YOU. THINK THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN BUT I THINK A LOT OF
CONFUSION HAS BEEN CREATED. BY
THIS REPORT BECAUSE IT'S BUILT
ON ONE MOMENT IN TIME- AND THEN
IT IS A DIFFERENT MOMENT OF TIME
THAT WE RELEASED THE BUDGET AND
THEN A DIFFERENT MOMENT OF TIME
THAT WE'RE- WE RELEASED. THE NAY
REALIZE AND I THINK IT REALLY
HAS. BRED A LOT OF CONFUSION AND
IT IS ALL. PROJECTIONS AND-
ECONOMIC. FORECASTING AND WHAT
WE THINK CONSUMERS ARE GOING TO
DO AND WHAT WE THINK THE
PLASTICS MARKET OR THE ALUMINUM
MARKET IS GOING TO DO AND
CLEARLY THE PANDEMIC. SET
EVERYTHING AS YOU- AND IN THE
LAST. COUPLE OF YEARS IN TERMS
OF THAT FORECASTING AND THAT AND
THOSE AT PROJECTIONS AND
ESTIMATES ETCETERA SO. I THINK
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS THIS
IS A VERY SMALL PIECE OF A
LARGER CONVERSATION- BUT HOW DO
WE GET THE LEGISLATURE. REAL
TIME INFORMATION AT THAT CAN
MAKE THE ABOUT THE PROGRAM THE
AND THE I HAVE BUDGET APPROACH-
AND THAT REALLY FACILITATES THE
DECISIONS THAT YOU WANT TO MAKE
AND I. LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU- ON AND IT- AT THIS
YEAR I'M ON- I KNOW HOW CAN WE
LOOK AT. THE RIGHT AMOUNT FOR A
HEALTHY SURPLUS VERSUS WHAT WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW WELL YOU KNOW. WE
HAVE AN OBLIGATION I MEAN YOU
GUYS HAVE AN OBLIGATION FINANCE
YOU HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO GIVE
THE LEGISLATURE COULD NUMBERS SO
THAT WE CAN WE CAN WE'RE
SUPPOSED THIS IS AN OVERSIGHT
WE'RE TRYING TO HOLD YOU. FOLKS
ACCOUNTABLE AND IN THE PUBLIC
NEEDS TO KNOW I MEAN WAS THE
PUBLIC ABLE YOU KNOW. JUST A
YEAR AGO I MEAN WE KNOW WE
STARTED OFF IN JULY WITH THE
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS- SURPLUS THEN YOU
ESTIMATED THAT IT WAS GONNA BE
FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY NINE IN A
REPORT TO LEGISLATURE LAST FALL
AND IN DECEMBER YOU SEND FINANCE
A LETTER. THAT WAS FIVE HUNDRED
NINETY EIGHT THAT PROMPTED THE
FIVE AND TWENTY NINE FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE THAT
PROMPTED THE LETTER SAID SHE IS
IN ONE YEAR MINNOWS ARE SORT OF.
PRETTY BIG NUMBER SO LIKE ACT
YOU KNOW. BY BOTH THE DAY. OF A
HUNDRED MILLION IS SORT OF.
THAT'S A LOT OF NICKELS AND
DIMES. A LOT A LOT OF NICKELS
AND DIMES AND- I KNOW EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS WHERE I AM ON. THE
DESIRABILITY OF IMPROVING AND
WE'RE JUST GOING THROUGH THE
NUMBERS CRUNCHES HERE HAVEN'T
HEARD ANY IDEAS AT ITS- FINANCE
OR THE MINISTRATION ON WHERE WE
CAN CHANGE A PROGRAM IMPROVE IT
BUT THAT. WE'RE JUST WE'RE JUST
GETTING. WE'RE GETTING DATA HOW
. I HAVE ALWAYS LIVED HOW IS THE
PUBLIC IN THE LEGISLATURE GOING
TO KNOW HOW WE'RE GOING TO
REALIZE THE MISTAKE WAS MADE I
MEAN I'LL BE HONEST I'M IN THIS
GAME. ARE RECYCLING I THINK
EVERYBODY ALL MY COLLEAGUES
THINK IT IS I DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT.
THIS WE WANT TO CALL OUR
ACCOUNTING PROBLEM UNTIL I READ
IT MOVE IN A COMICAL. I MEAN I
WOULD TO NOTIFY. MY NOBODY WAS
NOTIFIED. RIGHT AND AGAIN I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU
ON SOME CHANGES TO USE ACTUALLY
THAT WE CAN MAKE THAT WOULD-
PROVIDE MORE REAL TIME
INFORMATION TO YOU AND TO THE
PUBLIC. I DON'T I WOULDN'T
HESITATE TO CALL IT A MISTAKE.
AND SAY THAT ARE ESTIMATES AND
ARE PROJECTIONS WERE WRONG IT'S
I I'M NOT TRYING TO PARSE WORDS
HERE. BUT WHAT WE THOUGHT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN DIDN'T HAPPEN.
IS REALLY WHAT IT CAME DOWN TO
AND WHILE THE NUMBERS IN THE
BUDGET WERE BASED ON. BOOKS THAT
WE HADN'T CLOSED YET AND THAT
WAS REALLY THE ACCOUNTING ISSUE
THAT HAPPENS FROM TIME TO TIME
AND AGAIN THIS DEPARTMENT WAS
REALLY IMPACTED- IN TERMS OF OUR
ABILITY TO. CLOSE OUR BOOKS AT
THE END OF THE YEAR IN TIME FOR
THE JANUARY BUDGET- WE HAVE MADE
AT THAT TIME WE ARE PREPARED TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE. O
AND KEEPING YOU UP TO DATE WITH
THESE NUMBERS AS WE HAVE NEW
PROJECTIONS ARE NEW NEW
INFORMATION. BUT REALLY AS WE'VE
ILLUSTRATED HERE THE LAST TWO
YEARS ARE UNPRECEDENTED IN
HISTORICALLY COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE'VE SEEN.
EVER BEFORE AND SO YOU KNOW THE
DIFFERENCE OF ONE PERCENTAGE.
THE R. V. N. OR C. R. V. OUT IS
MORE THAN TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
A DAY. SO IT REALLY YOU'RE
DEALING WITH AS YOU VERY VERY
VERY WELL KNOW THOSE NICKELS AND
DIMES ADD UP TO BILLION OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS WELL OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR. I'M AND
WHAT WE REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE DOING IS PROVIDING
YOU THE INFORMATION YOU NEED SO
THAT YOUCAN ADEQUATELY
APPROPRIATE THIS MONEY- THAT
KEEP THAT KEEP THE FIND HEALTHY
SO. AGAIN WE WILL COME BACK TO
YOU FOR MAY REVISE WITH UPDATED
INFORMATION- AND AS YOU KNOW I'M
ALWAYS HAPPY ALWAYS HAPPY TO
TALK ABOUT. THIS PROGRAM AND ANY
OF OUR OTHER LIKE I GUESS IN
JANUARY YOU CAME UP- OR THE GOOD. THE BUDGET SAYS THAT THAT
WE'RE GOING TO SEE. OUR A DEAF
OR WE'RE GOING TO BE TOWARDS A I
THINK A HUNDRED TO NINE THE I'M
I'M SHUFFLING MY PAPERS RIGHT
HERE HOW DO WE GET TO THAT
NUMBER. MAYBE THE FINANCE NUMBER
IF IT'S NOT IF IT IS DIRECTOR
PLEASE. SO WE'RE NOT PROJECTING
A DEFICIT BECAUSE WE HAVE THE
SURPLUS. WHAT WE ARE SAYING IS
BASED ON. OUR PROJECTIONS OF THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY GOING OUT OF THE
FIND. VERSES THE AMOUNT OF
SIERRA COMING IN. IT IS THAT
THAT NUMBER IS BIGGER. BUT
BECAUSE OF THE CHANGES IN
CONSUMER BEHAVIOR THE CHANGES IN
THIS MARKET. OVER THE LAST. FIVE
YEARS OR SO WE'VE DEVELOPED A
SURPLUS AND IT REALLY DOES COME
DOWN TO YOU HOW MANY BOTTLES AND
CANS ARE BEING RECEIVED. AND I
USE THAT MONEY GETTING OUT THE
DOOR SO I DO THINK THAT THAT. BY
THE END OF THIS THAT THE NEXT
BUDGET YEAR AND WE WILL SEE THAT
SURPLUS GO DOWN BECAUSE WE ARE
SEEING THAT TREND AROUND
RECYCLING GO UP AGAIN- BUT- WE
ARE. AT YEAH I KNOW YOU DIDN'T
HEAR ME COME IN AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE YEAR AND- TELL YOU I'M
WORRIED ABOUT PROPORTIONAL
REDUCTION IN THE NEXT YEAR SO WE
ARE DEFINITELY NOT IN THE PLACE
WHERE WE THINK. THAT THERE WILL
BE A STRUCTURAL DEFICIT BECAUSE
THE SURPLUS HAS ACCUMULATED. SO
OKAY I'M LOOKING TO. RESTORE
SOME FAITH AND FOLKS- YOU KNOW
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF PILOT
PROGRAMS AND WE'RE GONNA GET TO
THAT IN A SECOND. BUT GENERALLY
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH RECYCLING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE WITH
TALKED ABOUT DESERT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THE UNDERSERVED WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT. WE'RE JUST
STARTING TO GET IT WHAT HAS
CHANGED WHAT WHAT CONSUMER
BEHAVIOR HAVE CHANGED IF. PEOPLE
ARE MAD ABOUT THE PANDEMIC%
DERMATOPHYTE IN PLACE. AT ABOUT
THIRTY EIGHT RUSSIANS INVADING
YOU KERN WHAT MAKES THEM. THANK
WHAT MAKES US THINK THAT NOW
THEY'RE GOING TO TRAVEL FIFTY
FIVE MILES TO RECYCLE THEIR
BOTTLES I MEAN WHAT WHAT. WHAT
IS NEW INFORMATION. FOR FRONT OF
YOU THAT WOULD RESTORE THE
FAITH. IN THE PUBLIC AT LARGE
ARE YOU SEEING LESS PEOPLE DOING
CURBSIDE IS THERE ANY DATA
THAT'S COMING IN. THAT WOULD
INDICATE. THAT IT'S WORKING.
WELL I WOULD SAY. YOU KNOW A
RISK RATE THAN IT DOWN TO
ROUGHLY SIX EIGHT PERCENT. HI IN
TWENTY TWENTY BUT THAT WAS WITH
MANY OF OUR RECYCLING CENTERS-
CLOSED FOR HEALTH AND SAFETY
REASONS. AND MANY PEOPLE AREN'T
NOT LEAVING THEIR HOMES WE WERE
STILL RECYCLING AND 68% AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT JUMPED
BACK UP TO OVER 70% I THINK FOR
FIGURING IT'S GOING TO BE AROUND
SEVENTY POINT SIX PERCENT- AS WE
FINISH COMPILING THAT DATA FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. SO WHAT WE
ARE SEEING IS PEOPLE ARE STILL
RECYCLING THAT THAT RECYCLING
RATE OVERALL IS IT IS PRETTY
AND- PRETTY STATIONARY THAT'S
NOT TO SAY THAT THAT THAT WE
SHOULD BE IMPROVING IT. I'M JUST
SAYING 70% IS A PRETTY HIGH
RECYCLING RATE FOR ANY PROGRAM
MUCH LESS- AT ONE THAT IS-
BRINGING IN. EIGHTEEN POINT
EIGHT BILLION BOTTLES AND CANS
LAST YEAR THAT IS AN INCREDIBLE
NUMBER. I THAT WE'VE NEVER SEEN
BEFORE SO I THINK. WE'RE SEEING
THAT THAT THOSE REDEMPTION
OPPORTUNITIES- NEED TO IMPROVE
THAT THERE ARE PARTS OF OUR
STATE WHERE DOES THAT WHERE WE
ARE NOT SEEING THAT RATE OF
REDEMPTION. THAT YOU MAY
EXPERIENCE AND- AND OTHER PARTS
OF THE STATE THAT WE ARE SEEING
THE AMOUNT OF RECYCLING GOING
UP. I ALSO LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT AS
AS A POSITIVE- AS YOU KNOW THE-
REPLANTED PUBLISHERS HAD. A
MAJOR IMPACT ON RECYCLING AND
CONVENIENCE DON'T- AVAILABILITY
I FEW YEARS BACK- BUT JUST IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS- WE'VE I'M ON
A BROAD ONLINE. THIRTY MORE
RECYCLING CENTERS AND THAT'S
DURING THE PANDEMIC SO THERE IS
IMPROVEMENT AS IT IS HAPPENING
BUT AS- AT AS AND YOU
HIGHLIGHTED SENATOR. AND WE TALK
ABOUT FOR A LOT OF YEARS THERE
IS A LOT OF ROOM. A YEAH I GUESS
SO WE HAVE THE LAW AUDIENCE.
REPLAY CLOSE TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FOUR SITES IN TWENTY
NINETEEN N. N. N. N. SO WE HAD
ALMOST A FULL YEAR. OF NOT
HAVING RE PLANET- WHEN WERE YOU
GUYS ARE MAKING PROJECTIONS IN
TWENTY TWENTY RIGHT SO THAT SO
WE KNEW THAT- N. AS- OKAY.
ANOTHER I GUESS MY QUESTION IS
ON THE PILOT PROGRAMS WITH THE
SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE TALKED
ABOUT- THAT THE ARTICLE-
HIGHLIGHTED ON SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES OF WANTED THE PROGRAM
START WHEN DID THE MOBILE
PROGRAM START THERE'S DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS OF THE PROGRAM- THE
JULY FIRST ST WERE VERSUS THE
ACTUAL DATE WHEN THE MOBILE
PROGRAM- STARTED CAN YOU SHED
SOME LIGHT ON ON THAT BECAUSE
WHAT I AM WHERE I'M GOING FOR MY
SECOND SHOULD SUPPLY THE FIRST
ONE I'M GOING IS THAT WE KNOW
THAT ALL THE OPTION BE PAYMENTS
STOPPED. AND I DON'T KNOW IF THE
REPLACEMENT ON THE RECYCLING.
WASN'T IN EFFECT. WELL AS YOU
KNOW SENATOR- THAT BUDGET PASSED
LAST YEAR SB ONE FIFTY FIVE-
CONTAINED A PROVISION THAT-
PROVIDED OUT FOR A YEAR- EIGHT
AND- AT HIATUS FROM PAYING
OPTION BE IF HE MET CERTAIN
SMALL RETAILER OF REQUIREMENTS
IN THIS WAS IN THE LEGISLATURE
TECHNOLOG MEN OF THE HARDSHIP OF
THE PANDEMIC HAS CREATED WAR
SMALL BUSINESSES AND SO. IT MOST
OPTION BE FOR THOSE SMALLER
RETAILERS THE SMALL BUSINESSES-
ARE NOT CURRENTLY I IN IN A FAX-
AS FOR THIS ONE YEAR PERIOD OF
TIME TO GIVE THEM TIME TO GET
BACK TO WHERE THEY WERE PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC I'M BUT YOU KNOW
SAN FRANCISCO IS AS A AS AS I
PUT IN MY RESPONSE SAN
FRANCISCO'S. PILOT PROJECT HAS
REDEEMED OVER TWENTY MILLION
CONTAINER SINCE IT BEGAN IN JULY
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND I WILL
GO TO SAY THAT WE'VE AUTHORIZED
THESE PILOT PROJECTS EARLIER BUT
AGAIN MUCH LIKE STATE GOVERNMENT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WERE REALLY
STRUGGLING DURING THE PANDEMIC
ESPECIALLY THE EARLY PART OF
PANDEMIC TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
OPERATE REMOTELY AND I THINK WE
CAN ALL SYMPATHIZE WITH THEM-
FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE INSTEAD OF
THESE PILOT PROJECTS AND TAKING
A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME- WITH THE
PILOT PROJECTS IT'S- A
PARTNERSHIP HAS TO BE BUILT
BETWEEN RECYCLERS- THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ENTITY- AND THE
PLACES THAT ARE GOING TO BE. AT
A CITING THE DROP OFF OR R. OR
PICK UP- OPPORTUNITIES AND SO IT
TAKES A LITTLE TIME TO FILL
THESE OUT BUT SAN FRANCISCO SO
FAR HAS- SENDS JULY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE RECYCLED MORE THAN
TWENTY MILLION CONTAINERS- AND
THEY ARE DOING AN INTERESTING I
THINK IT'S INTERESTING TO LOOK
AT THEIR PILOT PROJECT BECAUSE
THEY'RE TESTING A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF OPPORTUNITIES
SO MOBILE RECYCLING WILL BE ONE
OF THEM AS THEY'RE GETTING NOT
ONLINE. AND THE BACKDROP AND.
AND AS WELL AND THERE WILL BE
INTRODUCING SOME REVERSE VENDING
MACHINES I'M IN THE EARLY PART
OF THIS. YEAR'S SO ON DECEMBER
JUST GO IT WAS LITTLE I THE
UPTAKE BUT ARE. TO SOME OF THEIR
CHALLENGE AND A- I THINK- YOU
KNOW NONE OF US PREDICTED A
PANDEMIC AS WE ROLLED OUT THIS
PROGRAM OR ANY OF OUR OTHER
PROGRAMS AND- ARE REALLY TRYING
TO ADJUST TO GET THINGS BACK
ONLINE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
BUT I. THINK MUCH MORE
ELOQUENTLY W. CAN PROBABLY SPEAK
MUCH MORE ELOQUENTLY TO THE
SPECIFIC CHALLENGES THAT. I HAVE
A QUICK QUICK QUESTION ON
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES AND ALUMINUM
CANS I KNOW IT'S BECOMING
POPULAR WHY NAY CAN BOOST IN THE
CAN I CAN IS A CAN. YOU THINK.
HOW DO YOU THINK THIS ISSUE
SHOULD BE RESOLVED. I'M GLAD
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU KNOW HOW I
WOULD ANSWER THAT IS THAT I IT
WHEN I WAS STILL IN THE
LEGISLATURE AT UNITED AND
MATERIAL MATERIALIZE YOU SAID
AGAIN AS I CAN- AND THAT YOU
KNOW I WASN'T HERE WHEN THAT
STATUTE FIRST OUT THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN EIGHT AND A HALF PERCENT
AND NINE PERCENT- FOR
PARTICIPATION IN THIS PROGRAM-
BUT I'LL TELL YOU IT WOULD MAKE
MY LIFE EASIER IF IT. I CAN WAS
AGAIN. THE I JUST DON'T KNOW
HOW. THE PEOPLE WILL. ALUMINUM
IS GOING TO BE PROCESS JUST WHAT
IS NOT COULD BE CV. GET THE
DEPOSIT IT'LL JUST BE SCRAP
METAL IS THAT BECOME. RIGHT
THAT'S EXACTLY AND SENATOR THE
DEFICIT DOES NOT PERMIT US TO
COLLECT THE SIERRA ME ON THOSE-
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS- AND SO
THEY- HAVE TO BE RECYCLED- AS AT
. AS SEPARATE SEPARATELY- AND
AGAIN I THINK YOU KNOW AND I'M I
KNOW I'M TELLING YOU SOMETHING
YOU ALREADY KNOW BUT I THINK
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR US
TO- TAKE THIS PROGRAM AND OF ALL
THAT INTO WHAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS
FOR THE FUTURE OF OUR CIRCULAR
ECONOMY- I WAS SAYING TO
SOMEBODY THIS MORNING I WAS
LOOKING AT THIS THIS BOOK RIGHT
HERE THIS WHOLE BOOK RIGHT HERE
THIS IS THE WHOLE STATUTE. AND
THE STATUTE ALONE IS THE BOTTLE
BILL VERSES ARE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE ORGANIC STATUTE WHICH IS I
BELIEVE FIVE PARAGRAPHS THE
STATUTE IS INCREDIBLY
PERSPECTIVE ON HOW WE- AT WHAT
WE COLLECT AND WHAT WE COLLECT
ON AND HOW WE GET PAYMENTS AND
ON WHAT SCHEDULE WE GET
PAYMENTS. AND WE JUST REALLY
AREN'T ADULTS YOU QUICKLY ADJUST
TO THE CHANGING- STATE THAT WE
ARE- YOU KNOW I KNOW NEW
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS ARE COMING
OUR NEW BEVERAGES ARE COMING ON
THE MARKET ALL THE TIME. AND
SOME OF THEM I HAVE THAT JUST
ABOVE THAT ALCOHOL IS GREAT ART
A PART OF OUR PROGRAM BUT I
CAN'T. SUGGEST THAT ON THE- YEAH
AT THE- WHEN. GOVERNOR NEWS
FIRST TOOK OFFICE RECEIPT AS
LOOK OUR LETTER X. SOME- BURNESS
INTEREST IN FIXING THE PROBLEM
AND WE KNOW THAT THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION MADE EFFORTS AND
EFFORTS AND EFFORTS TO NO AVAIL-
I REQUEST THE LETTER S. THERE'S
NO PROPOSALS OF ANY SIGNIFICANT
SUBSTANCE THE BROUGHT FORTH IN
NOW THIS IS THE FOURTH YEAR OF
THE ADMINISTRATION SO I GUESS
THE QUESTION IS WHY. OR OF WHAT
HIS CHANGE WHAT WHY WHY NOT A
SIGNIFICANT- ADDRESSING OF THE
SERIOUSLY FALLS FLOOD- BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAM.
WELL SENATOR I THINK THE WAY I
WOULD ANSWER THAT IN AND WE'VE
HAD THIS CONVERSATION BEFORE ARE
THERE ISN'T THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT WAYS OF THIS
PROGRAM CAN BE FIXED AND I
THINK- I WON'T SPEAK FOR THE
GOVERNOR BUT FOR MYSELF NOW IN
THIS CAPACITY AS THE DIRECTOR I
REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHATEVER WE HELP BUILD FOR
HELPING BUILD OUT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD LIKE TO SEE IN
THIS PROGRAM. AND SO AS YOU KNOW
HAPPY TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO YOUR STAFF AS YOU-
WORK THROUGH YOUR BILL I DO
THERE ARE SEVERAL OTHER MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM WHO HAS A
BILL WE PROVIDE HIM TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AS WELL SO REALLY
ENDS AND A REFLECTION OF WHAT
THE LEGISLATURE WANTS TO DO IN
TERMS OF THIS PROGRAM WE WILL BE
HERE TO SUPPORT THE POLICY
DIRECTION THAT YOU LEGISLATE-
AND PROVIDE YOU THAT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT WAS SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN IMPLEMENT- BUT WE
REALLY WANT TO RESPECT THE FACT
THAT OBVIOUSLY YOU ARE THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH- AND YOU ARE
GOING TO DIRECT THIS POLICY AND
HELP YOU. DO THAT TO THAT TO THE
BEST OF OUR ABILITY. I WE HAVE A
BROKEN SYSTEM. AND WE DIDN'T GET
IT DONE IF WE DON'T HAVE THE
GOVERNOR IN AND WE HAVE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IS BEING
PROVIDED THERE'S A CHALLENGE
THERE'S A PHILOSOPHICAL
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS ON IF WE'RE NOT ALL
GOING TO- HAVE OUR BETTER ANGELS
TAKE IT TAKE CONTROL AND TRY TO
GET SOMETHING FIXED IS GOING TO
BE IS HI I APPRECIATE THE
DIFFERENCE THAT YOU GIVE TO THE
LEGISLATURE. AS I LOOK AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL SOME
OF THE DIFFERENCE SEEMS TO BE
EVAPORATING WHERE HE JUST
DECIDES I WANT TO DO IT THIS WAY
BUT UNLESS IT'S SOMETHING THAT
HE DOESN'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT
AND IT'S ALL OF A SUDDEN IT'S
DIFFERENCE TOWARDS THEM SO- WE
CAN LIVE WITH THAT I DIDN'T WANT
TO ASK I NEVER HEARD FROM
FINANCE WHAT WAS THE MINIMUM OF
THE RESERVE THAT THEY THOUGHT
THAT SHOULD BE IN THE ACCOUNT. I
MISSED OUT ON THAT. YES SIR
GENERAL PART OF FINANCE WE DON'T
ACTUALLY HAVE A SPECIFIC
MINIMUM- YOU KNOW IT IT IT
REALLY DEPENDS ON THE PLANET
I'LL GO I'LL JUST SAY THAT WE'RE
DEFINITELY STILL KIND OF
MONITORING THE HEALTH CONDITION
OF FUND AND- LOOKING TO BE KIND
OF WHAT THE TRENDS ARE GOING TO
BE MOVING. THAT NOT THEY AT ME
VISION THERE'S NO YEAH NUMBER
THAT PER SE THAT WERE SAYING
SHOULD BE THE MINIMUM OF THE DAY
SO FINANCES AWARE WE TALK THIS
FUND SOME LIKE IF DID IF YOU
JUST LANDED FROM OUTER SPACE IT
SOUNDS LIKE IT WAS A GREAT THING
SURPLUS FUND THESE ARE DEPOSITS
THAT CONSUMERS HAVE PAID THAT
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
REDEEM. THEY THEY PAID THEIR
NICHOLSON PAID THEIR TIME IN THE
SYSTEM IS SO BROKEN BUT THEY
HAVE NO PLACE TO GO NOW SOME
PEOPLE FOR CONVENIENCE WOULD DO
IT BUT MOST PEOPLE. YOU KNOW IF
I REPEAT EVERYTHING ELSE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT INFLATION AND
PROBLEMS WITH DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT PEOPLE ARE JUST
THROW AWAY TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS A
MONTH AND DEPOSITS THAT THEY
DON'T WANT TO GO BACK BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T GO TO THE STORE THEY
CAN'T FIND A RECYCLING CENTER.
THEY CAN'T THEY HAVEN'T FOUND
ONE OF THESE THIRTY NEW PROGRAMS
TO THE COME ON BOARD TO JUST
REACH REMEMBER THAT THIS IS THIS
IS THE CONSUMERS MONEY THAT
WE'RE NOT ADDRESSING OF IN AN
APPROPRIATE WAY I GUESS BECAUSE
WE GOT FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IT HASN'T BEEN
RETAINED. THAT HAS REDUCED ME
THAT WE SHOULD IT WITH IT WE
WOULD IN THE BEST CAUGHT
POSSIBLE WORLD WOULD ALWAYS BE
ZERO EVERYBODY WHO SPENT A
NICKEL GOT TO NICKELBACK RIGHT
AND WE WILL BE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE HATE. HOW WE PAY FOR. THE STAFF POSITIONS ARE- ALL
RIGHT A- WE WILL. CLOSE THE
CLOSE THE RIGHT NOW I'M GONNA
HAVE PEOPLE FROM POP THAT HAVE-
INFORMATION- FIVE. AM LOOKING
FORWARD WITH GREAT INTEREST TO
THE ADMINISTRATIVE MINISTRATIONS
ATTENTION TO THIS AREA IN THE
MAY REVISE WE MAY HAS MAP-
DIRECTOR MONCHI WHETHER WE MAY
HAVE YOU BACK AGAIN BEFORE THAT-
BECAUSE AS YOU AS YOU. INTIMATED
WE'RE GETTING INFORMATION LIVE
ON THIS AND I JUST- I'M PERFECT
THAT THERE'S SO MUCH MONEY IN
THE FUND AND WE DIDN'T KNOW IT.
THEN OR WE DO WORK WE TRY TO
MINIMIZE IT AND WE NEED TO DO WE
THE PUBLIC DEMANDS BETTER
PERFORMANCE FROM THIS PROGRAM OR
GET A DIFFERENT PROGRAM. AND
THIS ALL ALL LEAVE IT AT THAT
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME TODAY. AND
WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE WHICH IS C. WILDFIRE AND
FOREST RESILIENCE TAX FUND THIS
IS SB. FOUR FIFTY SIX WE HAVE
THE- NATURAL RESOURCES A- THIS
ORDER TO CREATE AN ACTION PLAN.
THE TASK FORCE SORRY IT'S- BUT
EVERYBODY IS SLEEP HERE ON ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR. THE NATURAL
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE SOMEBODY
BEFORE US. OKAY YES THIS IS A
GREAT TIME- DIRECTOR OF THE
GOVERNOR'S WILDFIRE FORCED
RESILIENCE TASK FORCE I AM I AM
ON MUTED BUT MY VIDEO IS NOT.
WORKING THERE'S A. IT'S BEING
CONTROLLED CENTRALLY OR NOT.
WELL. I MAY HAVE TO GO OUT AND
COME BACK IN. WITH YOU A
QUESTION AND- I THINK AT THE. WE
CENTER STERN REYES TO CAUSE
CONCERN ABOUT THE PATTERN
TRANSPORTATION ELEMENT WE
UNDERSTAND IT'S NOT WITH THE
RESOURCES- DIFFERENT THE
DIFFERENT ITEM. YEAH. YEAH SORRY
ABOUT THAT I HAVE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES THIS IS PATRICK
RIGHT TIME- DIRECTOR OF THE
GOVERNOR'S. A FORCES ELISE
JASPER'S HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY
OF MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. WHAT I WOULD
THOUGHT I WOULD DO CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES THAT WE CAN HEAR YOU
FINE AND I CAN SEE A- THERE.
WHEN I THOUGHT I WOULD DO- JUST
VERY BRIEFLY BEFORE WE GET TO
YOUR QUESTIONS IT IS JUST TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHERE WE'D
COME- I OBVIOUSLY DON'T NEED TO
SPEND A LOT OF TIME ON THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE FOREST AND
WILDFIRE CRISIS THAT WE'RE
FACING- MANY MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE HAVE BEEN VERY
ELOQUENT ON THAT AT THE HEART OF
WORK ON THAT- OUR JOB AT THE
TASK FORCE WAS TRYING TO PULL
TOGETHER A COMPREHENSIVE. PLAN
AND STRATEGY WHICH WE DID IN
JANUARY OF TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY ONE TO PULL TOGETHER ALL
THE ACTIVITIES OF THE VARIOUS
STATE FEDERAL AND OTHER AGENCIES
THAT ARE WORKING AT ALL THE
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF THIS
PROBLEM FROM. JILL FRIEDMAN
PROJECTS TO WOULD UTILIZATION TO
PRESCRIBE FIRE CETERA. WE LAID
OUT THAT PLAN IT WAS REALLY
MEANT TO. BOTH GUIDE THE
EXPENDITURES OF ORIGINALLY A
BILLION AND A HALF STAND AND
MORE EXPENDITURES ON. VARIOUS
ASPECTS OF THE PROBLEM TO ALIGN
THE AGENCIES GET THEM OUT OF
THEIR SILOS AND GET THEM.
WORKING TOGETHER COLLABORATING
COST SHARING. AND THE PLAN ALSO
INCLUDES A SPECIFIC LIST OF. I'M
NINETY NINE ACTIONS THAT WE ARE
TRACKING ON A REGULAR BASIS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ON TRACK
AND RUN TIME WITH DELIVERING. ON
THOSE ACTIONS MANY OF WHICH
WRONG FROM SPECIFIC LGISLATIVE
MANDATES. WE THEN RELAUNCH THE
TASK FORCE LAST SUMMER- TO BE
HONEST STATE LEADERSHIP TO
INCLUDE FEDERAL LEADERS LOCAL
LEADERS. TRIBAL LEADERS A
RECOGNITION THAT WE NEED A
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESS THIS. BEGAN WITH THE
PRIMARY FOCUS OF. OF AND
MONITORING AND EVALUATING THE
NINETY NINE ACTIONS TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE ALIGNMENT. AND ALSO TO
SCALE UP OUR EFFORTS AS AS YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A- A MILLION ACRE
TARGET BETWEEN FEDERAL AND NON
FEDERAL LAND- THAT WE'RE
SHOOTING FOR BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. AND SO WE HAVE A VARIETY
OF EFFORTS UNDER WAY TO TRY TO
GET THERE. I TEND TO THINK OF
THEM AS PART OF A ROAD MAP
INJECTION THREE BIG BUCKETS. AND
ONE IS A SERIES OF STATEWIDE
STRATEGIES FOR THINGS LIKE
REFORESTATION PRESCRIBED FIRE
WOULD YOU LOSE ASIAN PRIVATE
LANDOWNER ASSISTANCE TO MAKE
SURE. AGENCIES ARE COORDINATING
AND MOVING FORWARD IN EACH OF
THOSE AREAS. SECOND A
COMPREHENSIVE TRACKING SYSTEM.
SO THAT YOU AND OTHERS CAN BE
AWARE OF WHAT WE'RE
ACCOMPLISHING ON THE GROUND. AS
YOU PROBABLY KNOW ALL THE
AGENCIES ACCOUNT THINGS LIKE
ACRES TREATED VERY DIFFERENTLY.
WE'RE TRYING TO ALLOW ACT COME
UP WITH ONE CONSISTENT SYSTEM.
AND ALSO GO BEYOND ACRES TREES
AND BEGIN TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE ACHIEVING IN TERMS OF.
RESILIENCE CARBON STORAGE YOU
KNOW EFFECTIVENESS AT CETERA.
AND THEN FINALLY AND I THINK-
OKAY PERHAPS MOST IN THE
INTEREST OF THIS COMMITTEE IN
OTHER. IS BILL A REAL FOR AND
WE'RE GONNA TO GET THE DONE. I
KNOW IT'S A LONG STANDING
CONCERN OF THIS COMMITTEE THAT
THE RISKS AND PRIORITIES IN EACH
REGION ARE VERY DIFFERENT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT. WE ARE PUTTING
TOGETHER A FIVE POINT STRATEGY
TO TRY TO DEAL WITH THAT WE'VE
GOT A SERIES OF REGIONAL FORUMS
WERE MEETING REGULARLY WITH THE
LEADERS IN EACH REGION. TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THEIR ISSUES
SO THAT WE CAN. HELP THEM
ADDRESS THEM SECOND A SET OF
REGIONAL PROFILES ARE SCIENCE
DRIVEN. THAT RECOGNIZE WITH THE
KEY RISKS AND PRIORITIES ARE IN
EACH REGION. THIRD THROUGH THE
R. F. YOU PROGRAM THE REGIONAL
FOREST AND FIRE CAPACITY PROGRAM
BUT THE LEGISLATURE. CODIFIED
LAST YEAR TO BUILD A PIPELINE OF
REGIONAL PROJECTS THAT REFLECT
AGAIN THE PRIORITIES AND RISK IN
EACH REGION AND TO FUND THOSE
THROUGH A NEW CONCEPT THAT WE'RE
STARTING TO PILE IT WHICH IS
REGIONAL BLOCK GRANTS TO BE ABLE
TO SEND TO THESE REGIONAL
EFFORTS BLOCK GRANTS. TO COVER A
WIDE VARIETY OF PROGRAMS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND THEN FINALLY
DESERVES A REGIONAL TOOL KITS
RECOGNIZING THAT SOME REGIONS
ARE WAY AHEAD SUMMER BEHIND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE EVERY REGION
HAS THE LATEST TECHNOLOGY THE
LATEST TOOLS THEY NEED TO PLAN
PRIORITIZE AND GET PROJECTS
DONE. OF COURSE DOING ALL THAT
DOES TAKE RESOURCES ARE WE ARE
TRYING TO STAY LEAN AND MEAN
THAT THE TASK FORCE ITSELF WHERE
RELYING ON THE LEADERSHIP OF.
THE CALIFORNIA OR THE FOR
SERVICE IN OTHES BUT WE DO HAVE
A HANDFUL OF POSITIONS THAT ARE
IN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET TO RUN THE OPERATIONS OF
THE TASK FORCE INCLUDING A
COUPLE POSITIONS AT C. N. R. A.
A COUPLE WITH CAL FIRE. I IN
SOME CONSULTANTS SUPPORT TO KEEP
US MOVING SO WE HOPE YOU'LL LOOK
FAVORABLY UPON THAT- AND THEN
FINALLY I JUST WANT TO SAY HOW
MUCH ARE WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP ON THIS
TOPIC. ON FIRST AND FOREMOST OF
COURSE WAS. AGREEMENT ON THE ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
PACKAGE LAST YEAR I'M CERTAINLY
HOPEFUL HAVE AGREEMENT THIS YEAR
ON A PACKAGE OF. A SIMILAR
MAGNITUDE- AND THEN FINALLY
THERE'S A WHOLE SERIES OF BILLS
THAT PASSED LAST YEAR FALL ONE
THAT CODIFIED THE TASK FORCE
ACTION PLAN SEVERAL AND
PRESCRIBED FIRE LIABILITY EACH
ONE THAT CODIFIED THE REGIONAL
BUYER AND FORCE CAPACITY
PROGRAM. EACH OF THOSE BILLS.
HAS SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED OUR
ABILITY TO GET THINGS DONE ON
THE GROUND- INTO A LINE THE
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT OF OUR GOALS
SO CERTAINLY HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE AND- AFTER
TALKING MORE SPECIFICALLY ABOUT.
BY ANY ASPECT OF THE PROGRAM YOU
MIGHT ANTICIPATE SOME
LEGISLATIVE OF MORE AND
LEGISLATIVE AMBITION THAN WHAT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED IN
JANUARY BUT I DON'T WANNA GET
AHEAD OF MYSELF. ALLEY MISS
KIRSTEN- DO YOU HAVE A COMMENT
ON THIS- BUDGET REQUEST. I
DIDN'T CARE. AND SENATOR TELLING
YOU WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
ON WE HAVE AN IDENTIFIED
SPECIFIC CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL. CENTER STERN OF
QUESTION. YES THANK YOU MR- AND-
THANK YOU MISTER RIGHT FOR- PUT
ALL THIS TOGETHER AND- REALLY
TRYING TO THINK COMPREHENSIVELY-
ABOUT OUR STRATEGY I KNOW WE
WENT THROUGH SOME OF THIS-
THROUGH THE POLICY PROCESS LAST
YEAR NOW WE SORT OF WE'RE
SITTING HERE. AT THE BUDGET
PHASE OF IMPLEMENTATION- AND
WHILE WE WERE DEVELOPING POLICY
LAST YEAR ON THIS TOPIC OF
CODIFYING THE ACTION PLAN- I HAD
RAISED. THE QUESTION ABOUT
HAVING MORE QUANTIFIABLE
PERFORMANCE MEASURES AROUND- THE
HARDENING- IN DEFENSIBLE SPACE
PRONG OF THE STRATEGY- AND I'M
JUST WONDERING I KNOW THERE WAS
SOME RESISTANCE TO PUTTING
ANYTHING QUANTIFIABLE THAT WOULD
BE SOME KIND OF ANALOG TO. THE
ACREAGE TARGETS WHICH SEEM TO BE
A CENTRAL METRIC AND YOU KNOW I
DIDN'T HEAR ANY MENTION ACTUALLY
IN YOUR PRESENTATION ABOUT ANY
OF THE HOME HARDENING OUR
COMMUNITY HARDENING OR
DEFENSIBLE SPACE WORKING. SEEMS
LIKE THE BUDGET KIND OF REFLECTS
THAT- THAT PRIORITY IN IN THE-
CURRENT ATTENTION BEING GIVEN
TO- THOSE KINDS OF PROGRAMS BUT
I'M I'M WONDERING IN LIGHT OF
THE FACT THAT- APARTMENT
INSURANCE APPARENTLY HAS. A NEW
PROPOSAL THAT THEY'VE BEEN
WORKING ON WITH CAL FIRE AND-
YES HAVE YOU ALL- STARTED TO
DEVELOP SOME PER PERFORMANCE
MEASURES THAT THAT YOU INTEND
TO. TO HELP DRIVE- THAT PRONG OF
THE STRATEGY. YES WE DO WE HAVE
AN EFFORT UNDERWAY WE'VE GOT A
FIRE ADAPTED COMMUNITIES WORK
GROUP THAT INCLUDES THE-
LEADERSHIP OF- FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES AND KEY INTEREST
GROUPS TO TRY TO GET A BETTER
HANDLE ON. HOW DO YOU EVALUATE
COMMUNITY BY COMMUNITY WHAT'S
WORKING AND NOT WORKING AND WHAT
HE IS- A COMMUNITY THAT'S WELL
PROTECTED HOW DO YOU DEFINE THAT
OTHER A LOT OF DIFFERENT
MEASURES OBVIOUSLY AS YOU
MENTIONED YOURSELF. A PERCENTAGE
OF- RESIDENCES AND BUSINESSES
THAT HAVE HOME HARDENING THAT
HAVE DEFENSIBLE SPACE DO THEY
HAVE EVACUATION ROUTES. DO THEY
HAVE OUT OF REACH- THERE'S A
WIDE VARIETY OF RAZORS OUT THERE
ON THE DATE MOST OF THE FOCUS
HAS BEEN ON GETTING THOSE
INDIVIDUAL ELEMENTS OF THESE
PROGRAMMES UNDERWAY- BUT I'D BE
THE FIRST TO SAY THAT WE NEED TO
DO A BETTER JOB. OF TRYING TO
THEN ROLL THOSE UP AND BE ABLE
TO TELL YOU AND OTHERS HOW MUCH
PROGRESS ARE WE MAKING IN MAKING
COMMUNITIES RESILIENCE IT'S A
REAL CHALLENGE IN COMING UP WITH
A SINGLE DEFINITION OF WHAT
MAKES A COMMUNITY RESILIENCE-
BUT THERE IS AN EFFORT UNDERWAY
JUST TO ESTABLISH A SET OF
INDICATORS THAT WILL DO THAT.
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP
WITH A WITH A MORE DETAILED
CONVERSATION WITH YOU ABOUT
THAT. THANK YOU FOR THAT IN IN
IN TERMS OF THE REGIONAL FORUMS
THAT THAT YOU. DESCRIBED AT THE
OUTSET- DO YOU THINK THAT'S THAT
THAT FINING THOSE SORT OF.
MEASURES ARE THE PART. PART OF
THE WILDFIRE STRATEGIES GOING TO
BE A- FOCAL POINT CAN YOU GIVE
US A LITTLE MORE COLOR ON WHATWHAT WE SHOULD EXPECT AROUND
THESE THE REGIONAL FORMS YOU
DESCRIBE- YEAH I KNOW I DO THINK
THE REGIONAL FORMS ARE GOING TO
BE THE CIVIC CREASING LEE THE
CENTRAL WAY WHERE WE GET THINGS
DONE. I THINK FOLKS UNDERSTAND
THAT. AND WE'RE HEARING THIS
FROM ALL OVER THE STATE GOT A
LOCAL COMMUNITIES LOCAL RCTS
FIRE DISTRICTS SAYING. IF WE
HAVE TO GET THE JOB DONE THROUGH
COMPETITIVE GRANTS WE CANNOT.
SUSTAIN PROJECT YOU CAN'T RAMP
UP AFTER GETTING A GRANTED RAMP
DOWN HOPE YOU MIGHT GET A GRANT
FOR INDIVIDUAL PROJECT TWO YEARS
FROM NOW OR FIVE YEARS FROM NOW.
WE NEED TO MOVE COLLECTIVELY
TOWARDS SUSTAIN FINDING OF THESE
REGIONAL PLANTS. YEAH I'D BE THE
FIRST TO SAY THAT'S VERY HARD TO
DO IN YOU KNOW A SITUATION WHERE
BUDGETS ARE ANNUAL. SO WE'RE
TRYING TO COME UP WITH A WAY SO
THAT WE CAN BLAND PARTICULARLY
SOME OF THESE. YOU KNOW ONE
TIME. ASIANS OF MONEY WERE GAY.
THROUGH GRANTS TO AGENCIES SO
THEY'VE GOT SEVERAL YEARS OF
MONEY OVER TIME TO GET BLOCKS OF
PROJECTS DONE SO THAT THEY CAN
HIRE THE CONTRACTORS THE
CONSULTANTS THE CREWS. ARE VERY
HARD TO DO WHEN YOUR- YOUR
FUNDING STRATEGY IN YOUR
IMPLEMENTATION STRATEGY YOU KNOW
IS BASED ON A QUESTION AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT. YOU'LL GET A
COMPETITIVE GRANT OR NOT-
THERE'S A LONG STANDING HISTORY
THOUGH IN CALIFORNIA- GOING THE
COMPETITIVE GROUP ROUTE TO MAKE
SURE THE BEST PROJECTS GET
FUNDED SO WE'LL PROBABLY HAVE A
BLEND OVER TIME WE'RE
INCREASINGLY AS REGION'S
DEMONSTRATE TO ALSO THEY'VE GOT
SOLID PLANS. THAT HAVE BROAD
BASED SUPPORT THEIR PERFORMANCE
STANDARDS AND MONITORING THAT
ONCE THEY CAN MEET THAT TEST AND
HAVE A SOLID PLAN INCREASINGLY I
HOPING THAT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TOWARDS BLOCK GRANTS TO THOSE
ENTITIES SO THAT THEY CAN BE
DECIDING WHAT THE PRIORITIES ARE
IN THEIR REGION. RATHER THAN
FOLKS IN SACRAMENTO. AND MUSIC
TO MY EARS IN TERMS OF- TRYING
TO GET AROUND THIS SORT OF
SPORADIC CYCLE ESPECIALLY AS
YOU'RE DOING CAPACITY BUILDING
IN AREAS THAT DON'T HAVE MUCH-
BUT ON THAT NOTE I. I RECALL
THAT WE DO HAVE A CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION I THINK FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND ON
AT LEAST SOME ASPECT OF OUR OF
OUR WILDFIRE. MITIGATION
STRATEGY IS THAT HOW HOW MIGHT
YOUR TASK FORCE BE ABLE TO
ARTICULATE- SOME PRIORITY SAY.
FOR THOSE KINDS OF ON GOING
STREAMS- THAT THAT KIND OF ON
GOING SCREENING TO PROVIDE THIS
KIND OF. OR CAPACITY ASSISTANCE
IS THAT IS THAT ON THE TABLE.
THAT'S A GOOD THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION I THINK AS WE MOVE TO
DEVELOP THIS CONCEPT FOR BLOCK
GRANTS WILL OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO
WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
FINANCE TO FIGURE OUT. SOME
FUNDING STREAMS FROM BOTH THE
STATE SIDE IN THE FEDERAL SIDE
LEND THEMSELVES TO LONGER TERM
TIME HORIZONS AND OTHERS DON'T
OBVIOUSLY WE DO HAVE A NEED FOR
A ONE TIME MONEY FOR SHOVEL
READY PROJECTS TO GO AND GET
THINGS DONE. AND THEN WE HAVE A
KNEE NEED ALSO FOR SUSTAIN
PROGRESS SO WE'LL DEFINITELY BE
WORKING WITH THE WITH FINANCING
ADMINISTRATION AND LED STAFF TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE MATCH.
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF FUNDING WITH
DIFFERENT PURPOSES. SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK AND LOOK
FORWARD TO FOLLOWING UP OFFLINE
ESPECIALLY IF WE CAN HELP- ON
CORONATION ON SOME OF THE
REGIONAL SCALE I WANT TO SEE.
THIS THIS INSURANCE REGULATORY
APPROACH IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
ALWAYS REQUIRE GENERAL FUND OR
EVEN G. G. R. F. TO HELP BE A
DRIVER TO HAVE SOME KIND OF
SUSTAINABLE FRAMEWORK SO WE
DON'T JUST PRICE EVERYBODY OUT
OF THE FIRE ZONES BUT I. I'M
REALLY LOOKING ALSO TO YOU IN
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR A LITTLE
MORE CLARITY IN THIS TASK
FORCE'S STRATEGY AROUND. FURTHER
DEVELOPMENT INTO THE FIRE CELLS
WE KNOW THERE'S FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET TO DO INFILL DEVELOPMENT
AND NOT FIRE DEVELOPMENT BUT
THERE'S ALSO. BOARD OF FORESTRY
REGULATIONS THAT. HAVE RAISED
SOME HACKLES ABOUT ARE WE
ACTUALLY INCENTIVIZING NEW
DEVELOPMENT THERE I'D LOVE TO
SEE IN FOLLOW UP IN A DRESSED IN
THE STRATEGY YOU BRING BACK THE
LEGISLATURE. HOW TO ACTUALLY
MITIGATE RISK. BY LIMITING THE
AMOUNT OF NEW DEVELOPMENT AND
NEW HIGH RES DEVELOPMENT WE PUT
INTO THOSE ZONES AND WHAT
THAT'LL YOU'LL TO THE CHAIR
THANK YOU. I THINK VERY GOOD
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS MATTER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY- AND MOVE ON
TO- RIGHT SIZING OUR FIRE CREWS
WITH THE CONSERVATION CORPS-
THIS IS ISSUED NUMBERS. A DIRT
HAS COULD MORE. WELCOME TELL US
ABOUT RIGHT SIZE YOUR FIRE CREWS
. GET MORE YEAH SURE WHY BECAUSE
COMMITTEE BY- CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS BOTH- ONE WAY
AND I'M AND SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS- ARE TO BY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY. RIGHT GENERAL FUND OF
JUST ORDER ALLOWING STAFF
POSITION AND THEIR FOR TIME
FORMER BUSINESS SOME IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN BUT I CAN'T
BACK TO CALIFORNIA DROUGHT. WE
HAVE NO ARE. I'M IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN GATHERED TO FIRE IN WITH
CAL OR OTHER- OKAY A FIRE SENT.
A MEANS IN YEARS BAD- CREWS
THAT- CAN PLASTER THE ROLE
ARTURO LOS WATER CENTERED JOB ON
WALL STREET SO. IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. WE HAVE FOUR EIGHT PER
FIREFIGHTING. WITH THE YOU MORE
CRUZ YOU TO MORE YOU HIGHER RISK
OUT OF COUNCIL- EARLIER THE OR
THIS- ARE. ON THAT HAS NOT BEEN
HEARD YEAH SO TWENTY TWO TO
THREE YEARS EVEN MORE FIRE CREWS
WILL CHAD ADDITIONAL TEN
PERMANENT PART- AND IF THE
INSURING YOUR SO THERE'S A GREAT
FOR. THE STAFF SIDE. I'M HERE TO
GO ANSWER THE QUESTION YOU MIGHT
HAVE. MISTER SEA FROM THE ALSO
HE HAD ANY- OF. ON LOW LOS PETER
CENTER CAMERA THIS CENTER MY- TO
HEADQUARTERS. I'M SPECIFIC
CONCERNS THE PROPOSED WE DO
THINK IT PROBABLY MAY SENSE SAID
PROVIDE TO ME JUST RESOURCES IN
THIS AREA MORE J. AND WE DIDN'T
IT'S IMPORTANT KIND OF LOOK AT
THIS PROPOSED PROBABLY IN A OF
ALL OF THE OTHER DARK. THAT YOUR
STAY WE- I KNOW WE A WHOLE HERE
READ ABOUT A PROPOSAL AND
EVERYTHING IT'S IMPORT LOOK AT
BUT- WE DO THINK THAT A THESE
CREWS PROVIDE A VALUABLE
RESOURCE FOR THE STATE AND-
GIVEN THAT IT IN CREATE- YOU
KNOW TEMP TO MAKE SURE THE THESE
ARE. WELL AND- YOU CAN CAN AT
LEAST THE STATE. MISTER BENSON
WITH THE- OF FOR. OUR STAFF
RECOMMENDED. IS TO PROVE HIS
BUT- MISTER. SUBMITTED. OKAY
SORRY NOTHING BAD YEAH I KNOW I
WAS YEAH I KNOW I'D HEY WE THINK
THIS IS ARE ALWAYS A VERY
IMPORTANT FULL JUST TO KIND OF
MAINTAIN EXISTING FIRE THE PAST
YEAR OR SO DONE NOTHING REALLY
TO THE PRESENTATION- AND LATER.
COVERED IT WELL HI. DOCTOR SAID
A WEEK TO THE VOTE. OUR PORTION
WILL UC. A CONSIDER MOTION TO
APPROVE IT- REQUEST. THEY YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU CHAIR THE
SPRING CAL. ISSUE THE SEVEN
THESE. ARE BAD. FOR THE
LIVESTOCK- IT'S LIVESTOCK
PRODUCERS MANAGERIAL EMPLOYEES.
MR HENNING WELCOME. THANK YOU
SURE WHY CALCIUM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I NEVER HAVE NAMED
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
STATE FIRE TRAINING WITH CAL
FIRE OFFICE OF THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL. THIS GOVERNOR OFFICE
PROPOSAL IS FOR FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY THREE THOUSAND IN BUDGET
YEAR IN A HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE
THOUSAND AND TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AND ONE POSITION TO
IMPLEMENT TRAINING FOR THE
LIVESTOCK HOUSE PROGRAM. BASED
ON PREVIOUS ENQUIRIES FROM THIS
COMMITTEE INTERESTED
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE-
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION WE LOOK
AT HOW WE SCOPE THE ORIGINAL
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL TO
IMPLEMENT ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
OH THREE. REGIONAL
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN AVE LOOKED
AT DELIVERING THE COURSES USING
AN ONLINE COURSE DELIVERY
FORMAT. THE FEEDBACK THAT WE
RECEIVED IS THAT THE END USERS
PREFER DC BASED COURSE FOR
DELIVERY BY TRANSITIONING TO A
SEA BASED COURSE. WE HAVE
REVISED THE SCOPE OF THE
PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE THE
POSITION AND REDUCE THE COST TO
SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. YOU'RE STILL
REQUESTING TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO EXTEND THE IMPLEMENTATION TO
JULY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE THIS SIX MONTH EXTENSION
IS FOR THE COURSE PLAN TO GO
THROUGH THE STATE WIDE TRAINING
EDUCATION ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
AND THE STATE BOARD OF FIRE
SERVICES APPROVAL PROCESS I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS. MISS SINCE ALLEY-
HAVE A COMMENT. I'M SO WE
RECENTLY- HEARD ABOUT THE
INSTRUCTIONS CHANGE OF PLANS
WITH REGARD TO THIS PROPOSAL AND
HAVEN'T HAD A LOT OF TIME TO DIG
INTO THE SPECIFICS HOWEVER AND I
THINK IT'S JUST IMPORTANT TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO DETERMINE WHETHER
BUT IF THEY DO WANT THIS IN
PERSON OR- THE ONLINE COURSE.
WHICH MODEL THEY WANT TO CHOOSE
BECAUSE OF COURSE THAT'S GOING
TO DEPEND THAT'S GONNA- THAT'S
GOING TO INFORM THE RESOURCES
THAT ARE REQUIRED SO- WE THINK
IT'S CERTAINLY REASONABLE TO
CONSIDER BOTH OPTIONS AND- JUST
MAKE SURE THAT WHATEVER
RESOURCES ARE PROVIDED ARE
REALLY COMMENSURATE WITH THAT
YEAH. HALF A MILLION BUCKS SIXTY
THOUSAND YOU KNOW THERE'S A- THE
PUBLIC EXPECTS SOMETHING ALL
RIGHT- WE'RE GONNA HOLD MATTER
OPEN. CAN YOU GIVE US MORE
INFORMATION ON THE ONLINE. THE
PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE SO THAT WE
GET TO. MAY WE KNOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. THANK YOU CAL
FIRE LET'S MOVE ON TO DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL WILDLIFE IN. CRAB TRAPS
THIS IS COMMERCIAL FISHING
INSPECTIONS ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT.
DIRECTOR BONNIE GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MY NAME IS
CHUCK BONHAM AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH WILDLIFE.
LIKE THE PRIOR ISSUE THIS BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL IS HALF A
MILLION BUCKS AND THE PUBLIC CAN
EXPECT SOMETHING- THE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL ON ISSUE EIGHT
IN MY VIEW IS A CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AND ECONOMIC
STABILITY PROPOSAL. THE
DEPARTMENT SIX FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
OF ON GOING GENERAL FUND AND
THREE PERMANENT POSITIONS TO
IMPLEMENT SENATE BILL EIGHTY.
THAT BILL GIVES OUR DEPARTMENT-
THE INSTRUCTION THE AUTHORITY TO
IMPLEMENT WHAT'S CALLED AN OF
DISSERTATION PROGRAM FOR OUR
COMMERCIAL DUNGENESS AND ROCK
CRAB FISHERIES EXPAND OUR BIO
TOXINS SAMPLING. IN OUR
CALIFORNIA FISHERIES AND CREATE
BETTER CONSISTENCY FOR OUR HARD
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN IN THE
OCEAN YOU ARE CATCHING THESE
CROWDS AROUND SOME OF THE
OPENING CRITERIA BEGINNING OF
EACH SEASON. THIS IS A PROGRAM
THAT WILL HELP WE HAVE BROAD
SCALE KIND OF OR DESTABILIZATION
CHALLENGES. ARE MORE IN REGIONAL
COMMUNITIES ALONG THE COAST
REALLY STRUGGLING. AS CLIMATE
CHANGE THAT AFFECTING OUR OCEAN
THAT WILL HELP US KEEP GOOD
CLEAN SEAFOOD. ON THE PLATES OF
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE STATE.
LET ME PAUSE THERE AND SEE IF
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR ME.
LET'S A CHECK IN WITH THE- THE
L. A. YOU'LL MISS A SELLERS YOU
HAVE ANY- VIEWS ON UNHEALTHY
LEVERAGE LEVELS OF THE MULTI
CAST SAID OR OTHERS ALL THINGS
RELATED TO THIS PROGRAM. HI I
THINK YOU MISTER TO A LIST OF
THE WAY- I AM AGAINST UNHEALTHY
LEVELS STOCKS. WE DIDN'T ANY
CONCERN WITH THIS PROPOSAL YOU.
OUR LET'S THAT WE HAVE SET
MCGUIRE HAS QUITE PLEASE GO
AHEAD CENTERS DIESEL RESEARCHER
IN THE JOY. NOTICES THEY A
CONCERN WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT IT WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE FLEET ON THIS ISSUE
WE'VE HAD. IN ALL THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THAT IS NOTED ON PAGE
EIGHTEEN- THE STAFF REPORT.
EVERY YEAR THEY A CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
IN THE COPPER DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. EXPECTS CRABBERS
THE FLEET OUT OF THE GOODNESS OF
THEIR HEART THE SCHLEP OUT.
THROW SOME TRAPS IN THE OCEAN
CAPTION CRAB BRING IT BACK AND
THEN PROVIDED TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH FOR
TESTING. OUT OF THE GOODNESS OF
THEIR HEART. AND SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN WE SEEM SEASONS
CANCEL SEASON SIGNIFICAN
DELAYED. AND THE FLEET HAS TO
CONTINUE. TO DO THIS WITHOUT ANY
TYPE OF COMPENSATION IT'S PRETTY
RIDICULOUS. I SENT A MILLION
DOLLARS- THIS STATE SHOULD BE
COMPENSATING CRAB FISHERMEN FOR
THE WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING IF
THE STATE EMPLOYEE WERE TO DO
THAT IT WOULD COST- SIGNIFICAN
DOLLARS IF WE WERE TO CONTRACT
WE WOULD HAVE TO PAY FOR IT YET
THERE'S BEEN THIS. EXPECTATION
SINCE BEARS AROUND IN THIS STATE
THAT THE FLEET IS GOING TO DO IT
AND SIMPLY DOESN'T WORK ANYMORE
BECAUSE OF THE CHALLENGE SEASONS
SO- I KNOW THAT THE DIRECTOR IS
VERY WELL AWARE OF THIS- WE'RE
GOING TO NEED TO BE TO WORK THIS
OUT. BEFORE THAT- THE BUDGET IS
ADOPTED IN AGAIN IT'S LESS THAN
ONE MILLION DOLLARS THE BILL TO
COMPENSATE THOSE FISHERMEN WHO
HAPPENED TO BE ABLE TO GO OUT
AND CATCH THIS CRAP AND THEN
TURN IT INTO A STATE AGENCY TO
FILL A FLIPPIN MANDATE THAT THE
STATE HAS ON THE FLEET. SO AT
THAT IS JUST MY ONE CRUNCHY
PIECE- THAT I WANTED VETO DANCE
. OKAY MONTHS FOR HI WE WERE OUR
DISCUSSIONS WILL CONTINUE THEIR
STAFF FOR CONDITIONS TO HOLD
THIS MATTER OPEN WE DID HAVE
SOME CONCERN OBVIOUSLY WHEN I
HAVE A HAPPY OUTCOME I THANK YOU
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE- WILDLIFE
CONNECTIVITY. ACTIONS THIS IS
THE SB SEVEN NINETY PROPOSAL-
YES SURE. SO LIKE THE PRIORITY
ISSUE WHERE THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL IS IN YOUR SUBCOMMITTEE THE
SAME IS TRUE ON THIS ISSUE- I
ACTUALLY WE RE NOTICE THIS AND
WE'VE TAKEN THIS OFF THE
CALENDAR I FORGOT. I HAVE MY
FINAL PAPER HERE SO- WE WILL
COME BACK AND VISIT THIS IS A
DIFFERENT AT A DIFFERENT DATE-
OKAY BECAUSE WE GOT SOME CHANGES
SO. SORRY ABOUT THAT- IT'S OKAY
WE'RE DONE WITH YOU FLORIDA. WE
DON'T WILDLIFE FOR THE MOMENT
THEY WILL GO- TO THE PARKS AND
RECREATION AND ISHQ- OUR NEXT
NEXT ISSUE ON BONDS IN TECHNICAL
PROPOSALS. PROP. SIXTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT. MR DOING. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN BRUCE- MY NAME IS BRIAN
DELEON THE CHIEF OF THE SOLE
REASON THE BELLMAN FOR STATE
PARKS AND I'LL BE PRESENTING THE
DEPARTMENT ON THIS ISSUE I'D
LIKE TO FIRST START BY
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT WE'VE HAD
SOME BIG DIFFICULT EXPLAINING
THISISSUE CLEARLY THUS FAR SO
PLAY COULD NOT RECTIFY THAT
TODAY THE ISSUE BASICALLY HAS
TWO PARTS. THE FIRST PART IS
LARGELY TECHNICAL IN NATURE AND
IS RELATED TO HOW VARIOUS
ADJUSTMENTS AND DECISIONS OVER
THE PAST FEW YEARS HAVE RESULTED
IN APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN PROP SIXTY SAVINGS
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE THE
SECOND PART OF THIS ISSUE IS
MORE OF A POLICY QUESTION
REGARDING THE BEST USE OF THESE
LIMITED FINANCE ADMINISTRATION
ULTIMATELY DECIDED TO USE THESE
FUNDS. TO COMPLETE- CONTINUE CAP
CONTINUING CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS IN LIEU OF STARTING ONE
OR MORE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS- THIS IS NOT AN EASY
DECISION AS YOU KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT HAS SIGNIFICANT NEEDS
OF BOTH EXPENDITURE CATEGORIES
SO I'D LIKE TO START WITH THE
FIRST PART OF THIS AND DESCRIBE
SOME OF THESE CHANGES OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS THEY'RE VERY
BEEN VERY IS APPROPRIATIONS
REVISIONS FUND CHEFS THAT HAVE
IMPACTED THE AMOUNT OF PROP
SIXTY FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. AND AS OF
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
THE NET RESULT OF THESE CHANGES
PROVIDE A TOTAL OF SIXTY SEVEN
MILLION FROM PROP. SIXTY EIGHT
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. BEN
AND ENJOY TWENTY ONE. THE BUDGET
ACT ADDITIONAL ONE UNDER EIGHTY
FIVE GENERAL FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS. WE
SUBMITTED A LIST OF THESE
PLANNED PROJECTS INTO THE
LEGISLATURE IN SEPTEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE MAKING. CLEAR THAT
THIS LIST WILL NOT CHANGE AS A
RESULT OF THIS PROPOSAL. IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THIS PROPOSED
BUDGET ACT INCLUDES- THIS PCP
THAT WE'RE DISCUSSING TODAY FOR
REVERSION OF ROUGHLY FIFTEEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION PROP SIXTY
EIGHT SAVINGS- THIS IS POSSIBLE
BECAUSE OF A PORTION OF THE ONE
EIGHTIES HARRY FIVE NINE GENERAL
FUND PROVIDED IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. IT ABLE TO DEPARTMENTS TO
MAKE SOME ADJUSTMENTS TO
PREVIOUSLY APPROVED PROJECTS
INCLUDING THE ABILITY TO FULLY
FUND SEVERAL PARTIALLY FUNDED
AND UNDERFUND UNDERFUNDED
PROJECTS. EXAMPLES OF THESE
ADJUSTMENTS INCLUDE SHIFTING
FUNDING FOR SEVERAL PROJECTS
THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY ONLY
PARTIALLY FUNDED FOR THE FACE
FIRST PHASE OF CONSTRUCTION SUCH
AS THE PIGEON POINT LIGHTHOUSE.
WHICH WAS ONLY FUNDED FOR THE
REHABILITATION OF THE TOP
SECTION OF THE WHITE HOUSE. BY
SHIFTING FUNDING TO THE GENERAL
FUND FOR THIS PROJECT THE PARTS
WAS ABLE TO FULLY FUND. THE
RECONSTRUCTION OF THE ENTIRE
LIGHTHOUSE. SOME OF THE SAVINGS
GENERATED BY THE FUND SHIFT
ENABLE THE DEPARTMENT TO
INCREASEPROP SIXTEEN FUNDING
FOR SEVERAL PROJECTS. SUCH AS
THE MOUNT DIABLO ROAD REPAIR
PROJECTS WHEREBY FUNDING WAS
INCREASED BY THREE POINT THREE
MILLION TO EIGHT MILLION. TO
EXPAND PHASE ONE OF THE- ROAD
REPAIR PROJECT. IN ADDITION IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT PARKS IS
ABLE TO MEET THE REGIONAL TARGET
SPECIFIED IN THE BOND ACT PARKS
AND SET ASIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FROM PROP SIXTY EIGHT. ROUGHLY
THREE MILLION OF THESE FUNDS SET
ASIDE WERE ULTIMATELY NOT NEEDED
GIVEN PARKS IS PROJECTED TO MEET
REGIONAL TARGETS BASED ON
PROJECTS IDENTIFIED TO DATE.
FINALLY THE OTHER PROP SIXTY
SAVINGS WERE GENERATED ON THE
NATURAL AS ACTUAL COSTS WERE
LOWER THAN ORIGINALLY
ANTICIPATED. AND THIS IS SPREAD
OVER ABOUT EIGHTY DIFFERENT
PROJECTS IN AT LEAST ONE
INSTANCE THE SAVINGS WAS
ATTRIBUTED TO THE PROJECT NOT
BEING VIABLE AS A RESULT OF
REGULATORY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSTRAINTS. SO THESE FACTORS
RESULTED IN THESE SAVINGS OF
ROUGHLY FIFTEEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION APPROX SIXTY EIGHT. SO
THIS BRINGS US TO THE SECOND
PART OF THIS ISSUE AND THE
UNDERLYING QUESTION THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING HERE TODAY IS RATHER
THAN SHIFTING PROP SIXTY
FUNDING. ARTIST CAPITAL CAPITAL
OUTLAY WHY NOT START NEW
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
WITH THE FIFTEEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS. THAT IS YOU
KNOW ALL STATE PARKS AS A
SEPARATE SIGNIFICANT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS AND WE COULD
HAVE STARTED ONE OF MORE
PROJECTS WITH THE STAVING
DESCRIBED. FIRST TO DETERMINE
THAT WOULD BE MORE PRUDENT TO
RESERVE THESE FUNDS IN THE NEAR
TERM TO COVER INCREASED COSTS ON
EXISTING PROJECTS. S. A PARTIAL
RESTRAINING THESE FUNDS ON NEW
PROJECTS AND THEN FAILED TO
SECURE THE NATIONAL CAPITAL THE
FUNDING NEEDED. STATE PARKS
WOULD HAVE BEEN PUT IN THE
DIFFICULT POSITION OF HAVING TO
STOP OR REDUCE CONTINUING
CAPITAL IT PROJECTS. TO STAY
WITHIN AVAILABLE FUNDING. GIVEN
THE UNCERTAINTY OF ADDITIONAL
FUNDING BECOMING AVAILABLE THAT
TIME. THIS STRATEGY WAS INTENDED
TO HELP ENSURE THE COMPLETION OF
EXISTING PROJECTS. BUT ALSO
PRESERVING THE OPPORTUNITY SEEK
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND START
MORE PROJECTS IN THE FUTURE. SO
WITH THAT I CAN CLEAR MY AT MY
PRESENTATION AND WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
MR SINGH WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- SO AS YOU HEARD FROM THE
DEPARTMENT THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
REVERT ROUGHLY SIXTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN PROP SIXTY EIGHT BOND
FUNDS THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
APPROPRIATED TO THE PARKS
DEPARTMENT FOR ITS ARE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG. BASICALLY
BY DIVERTING THESE BOND FUNDS
THE DEPARTMENT WOULD MAKE THEM
AVAILABLE TO COVER COST
INCREASES THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS EXPERIENCED RELATED TO SOME
OF ITS CAPITAL PROJECTS- I HEARD
ABOUT THAT AS WELL WE DON'T HAVE
SPECIFIC CONCERNS ABOUT
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR
THIS CAP OUT LIKE PROJECTS AND
WE WOULD NOTE HOWEVER THAT
BECAUSE THERE'S NO BACK FIELD TO
THESE FINDS THE NET EFFECT
REALLY- AT THIS PROPOSAL IS
BACK. AND THEY WOULD BE LESS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FUNDING
PROVIDED TO THE DEPARTMENT-
COMPARED TO WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND WE DO KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT REALLY HAS A VERY
EXTENSIVE BACKLOG OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS I TOTALING
ABOUT ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS AND WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE TO ADDRESS
THAT BACKLOG AND YOU KNOW
BECAUSE SOME OF THESE PROJECTS
ARE REALLY- CRITICAL PROJECTS.
SO WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER I'M KIND
OF ITS ITS COMFORT LEVEL WITH
AND THIS ACTION WHETHER IT WANTS
TO- TO TAKE THIS ACTION OR
WHETHER FOR EXAMPLE ONCE YOU
CONSIDER BACK FILLING AND SUMMER
ALL OF THOSE FRIENDS AND REALLY
DEPENDING ON HOW MUCH. IT WEIGHS
THERE'S DIFFERENT PRIORITIES.
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS AS
PARTNER FOR. OF THE- PARKS AND
RESORTS DEPARTMENT SAID THEY
REALLY THAT THIS IS THE BEST USE
OF- AFTER. MUCH SO SEARCHING OR
SOME SEARCH- I AM I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS THAT YOU HAVE. THE
SECOND SOME LIVE HERE BECAUSE
YOU'VE GOT THE LAKE FERRIS STATE
RECREATION. AND I GUESS YOU KNOW
I KNOW ENOUGH PEOPLE THAT WOULD
SAY OH WE'RE JUST GOING TO DO A
99% RENOVATION HERE YOU SEE
THESE PEOPLE IN THE HOUSE FOR
THE KEEP ONE WALL UP IN A
COMPLETELY BUTTE REBUILD THE
WALL BECAUSE YOU'RE TRYING TO
GET AROUND. SOME LOCAL HOUSING
ORDINANCES THAT YOU CAN'T DO
WITHOUT THE KNOCKDOWN POLICE
WERE BEING HONEST THAT THE THIRD
LIFEGUARD HEADQUARTERS AT LAKE
FARE AS FOR THE- COLONEL
ALLENSWORTH STATE PARK IT'S
GOING TO. RESULT IN A NEW
VISITOR CENTER AND THE OFFICERS
CENTERS CRITICAL KAPUT. WHY IS
THAT THE BEST USE OF THE FUNDS
RATHER THAN THE DEFERMENT. I
MEAN OF RATHER THAN JUST GENERAL
MAINTENANCE BECAUSE WE GOT STILL
HAVE EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. EVEN IF WE PUT THE
FIFTH SIXTEEN AND THERE. YES
GOOD MORNING MY COULD GET US
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO THIS ONE TIME THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PRIORITIZING
CAPITAL PROJECTS AS A MEANS OF
INVESTING IN THE IPROVEMENT AND
RESTORATION OF THE STATE PARK
SYSTEM. THE MAJORITY OF CAPITAL
PROJECTS AND IN PARTICULAR THESE
PROJECTS WILL BE FUNDED THROUGH
THIS FOR VERSION WHAT REALLY
EMPHASIZED ON THE RESTORATION
AND IMPROVEMENT OF THE PURCHASE
SPEND WAYS THAT ARE
CHARACTERISTICALLY SIMILAR TO-
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ALTHOUGH
THERE ARE SOME- DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THE TWO. AND ULTIMATELY
THESE PROJECTS WILL HAVE A
SIMILAR EFFECT OF FOCUSING ON
IMPROVING THE VISITOR EXPERIENCE
AT THE PARK SYSTEM. I WAS
SURPRISED THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET DID NOT PUT ANY
ADDITIONAL MONEY AND FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND
ACTUALLY SURPRISED THAT THERE
WASN'T ANY MONEY IN FOR-
WILDFIRE PREVENTION ON THE PARKS
WHICH IS YOU KNOW WE- AT LEAST
THE MEMBERS OF THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
UNDERSTANDS THE CROSSOVER
BETWEEN. YOU KNOW WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND FITTING OF FORCE
ON STATE OWNED LANDS ACTUALLY
HELPS OUT WITH THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IS SOMETIMES. THIS
THE TREE LINE ON THE TRAIL HIGH
CASES IS THE- IS THERE SOME
REASON. THAT THAT YOU DID THAT
YOU SAID YOU THIS I SEE THIS
PROPOSAL'S GOING ON CAPITAL
OUTLAY BUT TO SORT OF. THIS-
PHILOSOPHY THAT I'M MISSING.
WITH THE WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION. WELL THEY HAS
BEEN A BROADER AND- ON CAPITAL.
IN THE GOVERNOR BUDGET I DID YOU
KNOW NOTE THAT ADMIN. EVALUATES
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE NEEDS ON
ESTATE LEVEL ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
IN LIGHT OF AVAILABLE RESOURCES
RECENT APPROPRIATIONS AS IT
RELATES TO OTHER PRIORITIES. I
GUESS WE'LL LEAVE IT THERE-
SENATE MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO MUCH
MESSAGE HERE I'M JUST GOING TO
REITERATE YOUR POINT- ABOUT WE
ARE SPENDING TIME ON THE SIXTEEN
MILLION WHEN WE HAVE OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS IN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND I'M GRATEFUL
THAT WITH THE PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS WERE ADVANCE TO BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT CRITICAL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE SYSTEM. IN THE BOTTOM
LINE IS WE SHOULD REDOUBLE THOSE
EFFORTS THIS YEAR I GET IT WE
MAY NOT HAVE TO PAY INTEREST ON
THIS FUN OF THESE FUNDS THAT
THAT WOULD BE ADVANCE AND IT'S A
DROP I THE BUCKET COMPARED TO
WHERE WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO GO
AND WOOD SINCERELY HOPE
ESPECIALLY SINCE SOME OF THESE
PROJECTS ARE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE WATER SUPPLY.
RESTROOM FIRE WATER SUPPLY
EMERGENCY INGRESS AND EGRESS OUT
OF CAMPGROUNDS- THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO REDOUBLE OUR EFFORTS IN
ADVANCE ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
NUMBER WHAT WE DID LAST YEAR
INTO STATE PARK SYSTEM WITH THIS
SIGNIFICANT SURPLUS AT THAT AT
THE STATE IS WITNESSING THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER. OKAY BUT
SEPARATE PROVISIONS WE HOLD THAT
MATTER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE PRESENTATION- WE'RE DRAWN ON
THE ISSUE NUMBER NINE AND WILL
NOW MOVE TO- ANYONE WANTING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT REGARDING
ITEMS THAT WERE ON TODAY'S
AGENDA AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPATION NUMBERS.
877-226-8163 IN THE ACCESS
NUMBER IS. TWENTY SIX FORTY FIVE
ONE TWO FIVE NOW DO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF HEARINGS AND TECHNOLOGICAL
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
PROTOCOLS- COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE- TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH
ANY WITNESSES- HERE IN THE ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE WHO'D LIKE
TO- TESTS FIVE. STROKES IN YOUR
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- MICROBES HERE
FOR THE PACKAGING INSTITUTE-
FROM THE ON THE ON THE- THE
OVERSIGHT OF THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAM AND
JUST. REALLY QUICKLY WANT TO-
PRECIADO. CHERRY TO CREATE THE
COMMITTEE TAKING TIME TO DO
OVERSIGHT OF THE DEPARTMENT-
ESPECIALLY ON THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAMS
INCREDIBLY COMPLEX PROGRAM. AND
WE'D BE OF THE OPINION THAT- YOU
SHOULD DO REGULAR AND- YOU KNOW
SUBSTANTIVE OVERSIGHT ON THIS
PROGRAM ALL THE TIME FOR ALL THE
REASONS HE STATED DURING THE
HEARING- WE WANT TO CALM. ON THE
- THE DIRECTORS OF THE- STEPHEN
ABOUT THE NEW MISSION STATEMENT
FOR POWER CYCLE- REGARDING
CIRCULAR ECONOMY AND WITH THAT'S
BECAUSE THE GLASS PACKAGING
INSTITUTE AND WITH THE
COMMISSION THE CONTAINERS THEY
MAKE ARE TRULY CIRCULAR. A GLASS
BOTTLE IS 1100% RECYCLABLE AND
CAN BE RECYCLED OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN IS TRULY THE
EPITOME OF A OF CIRCULAR- WE
WOULDN'T. WANT TO SAY THOUGH-
THE REASON THE REASON THAT
SISTER IT'S A- CIRCULAR PRODUCT
THOSE BECAUSE OF THE PRIMARY
NEEDS FOR BEING A RECYCLED
PRODUCT IS THROUGH THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER PROGRAMS WE HAVE A LOT
OF INTEREST IN HOW THATPROGRAM
WORKS. AND AS THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE NOTED IN THEIR
LETTER TO CARRY CYCLE THE
PROGRAM HAS FLAWS IN ONE OF THE
FLAWS AS A CLASS IS NOT MAKING
THE CIRCLE- THAT THAT DESPITE
ALL THE SUCCESS OF THIS PROGRAM
OVER THE YEARS AS ITS STATES
RIGHT NOW CALIFORNIA GLASS
CONTAINER MANUFACTURERS ARE
GETTING THEIR RECYCLE GLASS.
THIRTY IMPORTING CLASS FROM
OREGON AND OTHER STATES DESPITE
THIS PROGRAM AND ALL IT DOES THE
GLASS CARE MANUFACTURERS IN
ORDER TO MAKE THEIR MINIMUM
CONTENT MINIMUM RECYCLED CONTENT
REQUIREMENT TO MEET MEET THE
DEMAND OF THE OF THE LONG
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE TO BRING IN
RECYCLE GLASS IN CALIFORNIA SO
THAT'S A SERIOUS FLAW. AND- WE
THINK THERE ARE SOLUTIONS FOR
THAT WE- WE WANT TO WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE WOULD WANT TO WORK
WITH CAL RECYCLE WE WANNA WORK
THE POLICY COMMITTEES ON ON ON
WAYS TO IMPROVE AND IMPROVE
THAT- WE THINK ONE OF THE
SOLUTIONS IS TO REVISEREFORM
REDEFINED THE CURBSIDE PROGRAM
FOR SUCH A LOT OF MATERIALS TO THE CURB. AND WE DON'T
THINK THAT THAT'S KEPT THAT THAT
THAT THAT CURBSIDE PROGRAM AS IT
PERTAINS TO THE RESET TO THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER PROGRAM HAS
KEPT PACE WITH- WITH WITH ITS
NEEDS AND SO WE WOULD LIKE TO
WORK WITH YOU AND THE COMMITTEE
AND- AND THE. DEPARTMENT ON HOW
TO FIX THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. FOR PART NO WITNESS HERE
THE THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT-
WE WILL BEGIN NOW. MODERATOR YOU
PLEASE OPEN LINE TO CALL MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC INDIVIDUALS WILL
CONCUR WILL CONTINUE. I DON'T
LIKE TO COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE KEYPAD
PROPERTY WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER LISTED THREE
LINE NUMBER TO BE CALLED.
ALL RIGHT LET'S MODERATE GO HEAD
AND PROMPT THE FIRST A- PERSON
WISHING TO TESTIFY
TELEPHONICALLY WERE READY.
OUR FIRST THE GOVERNMENT WILL
COME FROM LINE NUMBER TWENTY TWO
POINT TWENTY TWO LINES OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY TWO WAS
DROPPED Q. ONE TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD.
TODAY ALL THE FUNDED SEEN
SURPLUS GROW OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS AND WE
PLAN TO CLOSE THEIR SITE. IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. THERE'S AREAS
OF THE PROGRAM WORKS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THIS YEAR RETENTION
RATE- BETWEEN SEVENTY AND 80%
BUT UNFORTUNATELY IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA THE BAY AREA
REDEMPTION RATE. IS WOEFULLY
AROUND 30% THE STATEWIDE
REDEMPTION RATE IS NOW
APPROXIMATELY 60% THE REQUESTED
I WOULD HAVE IS FOR THE SENATE
THE LEGISLATURE TO LOOK AT YOU
SEEN THE ON READING TO FIND THE
SURPLUS THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
USE IT TO HELP OPEN UP
REDEMPTION CENTERS REVERSE
VENDING MACHINES OR BAG DROP
SYSTEM. IN ALL THESE AREAS WHERE
PEOPLE HAVE FORGOTTEN HOW TO GET
THEIR DEPOSIT BACK THEY JUST
ACCEPTED THE PROGRAM OF THE TAX.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. AND WE ARE
AVAILABLE TO HELP WITH ANY
SOLUTIONS FOR THE PROGRAM THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT. BUT ONCE
AGAIN FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
PRESS ONE ZERO PLEASE OUR NEXT
FROM THE COMPLETE LINE NUMBER
TWENTY ONE TWENTY GO AHEAD
PLEASE. YES MY NAME IS LEONARD
LANG I'VE BEEN WITH THE PROGRAM
SINCE THE BEGINNING IT'S KEPT
BUT PERCENT SURGE COURAGE. SLEPT
I HAVE BEEN IN IN THE- AND THIS
AND BASS WITH THE BIGGEST
PROCESS RECYCLING NETWORK UP
UNTIL TWO THOUSAND NINE SEVEN
AND THEN I WENT INTO BUSINESS
AND STARTED CONSULTING WITH
RECYCLERS TO COP THEM DEAL WITH
THE AGES OF THE PROGRAM- THERE
HAVE BEEN TO A LOT OF THIS
PROGRAM 200-010-2000 FOURTEEN
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THOSE
AUDITS WERE NEVER IMPLEMENTED
AND I WOULD- ENCOURAGE YOU TO GO
BACK AND LOOK AT THOSE
EXPECTING. FOR THIS TO CHESTER
GOING. WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE BALANCES IN THE FUND. I
WOULD ALSO RECOMMEND THAT YOU.
INITIATE A THIRD AUDIT TO- COVER
ENFORCEMENT CERTIFICATION AND
DORIS ARE MOVING THE PROGRAM
AGENCY AND TO- PERMANENT
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS IF YOU
WANT TO HELP BY MR ROBESON IN
THE GLASS INDUSTRY HE WILL BRING
BACK COAL MINGLED WHICH WAS
ELIMINATED WHEN THE- FUND WENT
NEGATIVE- IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT
THE DEPARTMENT IS DOING. URBAN
IS NOT FOCUSED ON. KEEPING
RECYCLERS AND BUSINESS IN FACT-
TODAY- RECYCLING CENTER IN A
CONVENIENCE ON IN HIS. AREA IS
BEING FORCED TO CLOSE I HELP
KEEP A RECYCLING COMPTON IN
BUSINESS BY- TESTIFYING IN A
HEARING AS AN EXPERT WITNESS-
THERE ARE MANY RECYCLERS THAT
ARE BEING PUT OUT OF BUSINESS
THAT DO NOT NEED TO BE PUT OUT
OF BUSINESS IN THE BEGINNING THE
PROGRAM DEVELOPED ON A BASE OF
AUDITING FOR COMPLIANCE AND
ENFORCEMENT FOR. BY ONLY. YOU
WILL NOT FIND ANY RECYCLERS
BEING AUDITED THEY'RE ONLY
BEING. ADDRESSED BY ENFORCEMENT.
ENFORCEMENTIN THE HAMMER SHE
EVERY RECYCLE ENGINE NAGLE AND
THEY WANT TO PUT HIM OUT OF
BUSINESS. I HAVE PLENTY OF-
DOCUMENTATION ON THIS AND I HAVE
APPROACHED THE DIRECTOR. BECAUSE
I KNOW THAT SHE'S NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THESE THINGS SO I HAVE
ATTEMPTED TO WORK WITH HER AND I
WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT. BUT
THERE ARE MANY THINGS THAT COULD
BE DONE TO MAKE THIS PROGRAM.
WORK BUT IT'S NOT BEING DONE NOW
. THE QUESTIONS NO THANK YOU MR
LINE. I YOU NEXT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR NEXT TO THE LINE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LUNGS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOU MAY BE
NEEDED ON THEIR ANKLES KALRA. MR
SURE THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IS IN QUEUE WITH THE
STOCK. OKAY- OKAY ARE. HI THURS
THAT WILL CONCLUDE OUR PUBLIC
HEARING THIS SPRING AFFECTED
TODAY AS- THE CHAIR WILL
ENTERTAIN MOTIONS ON ITEM ONE
TWO THREE AS WELL AS SIX SOME OF
HIS MOTION BY SEN ACQUIRED THIS
THESE ARE ITEMS ON THE AGENDA
ONE TWO THREE AND SIX THIS ROY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CASKEY BY
DIALING. REQUIRE STERN RIGHT
BOTH. CLOSE REAL TELL YOU BOTH
SEE I SEVEN THREE ZERO- AND
THOSE MATTERS ARE APPROVED THANK
YOU- SENATORS THIS IS A SPECIAL-
WAS LIKE THE OLD DAYS WHEN WE
HAD. THE SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS
ON THURSDAY AFTER SESSION I'D
LIKE TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS ARE PARTICIPATING
TESTIMONY TODAY. IF YOU WERE
UNABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMONSENSE IS IT
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
WE WANT TO. CLEAN YOUR TESTIMONY
IN THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU
EVERYBODY- THE- MEMBERS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION TESTIFIED AND
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE COOPERATION
WE WILL WE HAVE CONCLUDED
JENNIFER TODAY'S. HEARING THE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE TO RESEARCHERS.